excuse this long introduction it's a bit
different
but this preface can be skipped you can
go to the time stamp there
if you want to get straight to the
bernardo castro up in john verveiki
conversation
many of you may be new to this channel
and if so my name is kurt jaimungle
i'm a filmmaker as well as i have a
background in math and physics and i'm
intensely interested in something called
theories of everything
now this includes the standard unified
field theories that
i'm sure you've heard of but it also
includes the philosophical theories of
everything such as
that of carl fristins or donald
hoffman's or
ian mcgill chris each of whom i've
interviewed on this channel and the
links will be in the description
this episode features two titans of
their respective positions
bernardo castro defending idealism that
is
the philosophical doctrine that we are
all part of the same mind or at least
that
all that exists our mental states rather
than a material reality whereas john
vervicky takes the position of monism
and naturalism when i speak to the
different prodigious
interviewees on this channel i generally
ask them about their views on
other intellectuals such as douglas
hofstetter or what do you think of roger
penrose's idea of orchestrated objective
reduction
and so on and i in a tongue-in-cheek
manner call it
theomaki that is to say battle of the
gods
now clearly this is facetious because
it's a sin or at least i think it's a
sin to consider any human a god
but there is some truth in the sense
that they're god-like in their
intellectual and
cognitive prowess however this episode
is
different first of all it's the first
time i've had on two people at once
and i'm less interested in critiquing
that is battling skirmishing than i am
about getting the interviewees to
understand one another's positions
and constructively critique if they're
going to critique at all
so i call it theo locution and it will
likely be a new series
started on this channel as well donald
hoffman was supposed to show up but
wasn't able to and it actually turned
out wonderfully because
castrop and verveiki had so much so much
to talk about and if you read the
comments or i'll
list some of the comments right now it
seems like it's one of the best
interviews or podcasts on this channel
in other news
the patreon for this channel is going to
be revamped as it stands right now
it's currently 100 for support i do zero
in terms of making a nicety like signing
cards and mailing it to someone or
creating a custom video i don't have
time for that
it's my time is i feel already stretched
to my
my limits as it is but there may be a
way to integrate the work already
conducted
into incentives for patrons so for
example
i may be writing a book on theories of
everything
i definitely take notes on the different
interviewees
as research and what i can do is publish
some of that or
give some of that to the different tiers
people seem to be interested in that as
well as
watching or being with me while a live
stream a studying session
for some of these interviews that's
another incentive for a certain tier
there are other ideas i have and i'm
also interested in hearing what
perks you think i should offer but the
whole point of this is that this channel
is growing
it's growing it is it's extremely
flattering that it's growing it's
a rate that i didn't think it would it
far surpasses my expectations for what
people
are willing to listen to a three-hour
conversation
on on meticulous technicalities and
intricacies and abstruse mechanics of
these different
theories and theorists while
simultaneously is
taking a huge toll on me both physically
for sure
i'm exhausted much of the time and then
spiritually yes because it's
destabilizing to
have to entertain many different ideas
as to what the heck reality is
and then cognitively for sure studying
for this is
difficult it would be great if just the
patreon covered income and then this way
i could find time to spend
and relax and even sleep while i sleep
but sleep well
and spend time quality time with my wife
and quality time with my family
plenty of that is mismanagement of my
own time but
it's also the stress of
uncertainty as to what i'm going to do
for income and so on
and hopefully this would mitigate it
another another reason
is that i'd like to invest in equipment
so for example
i was lent this green screen yesterday
by
someone who's been a fan of the channel
for months and has been helping out with
the discord his name is phil
chertook phil thank you thank you so
much phil
the reason for this green screen as an
aside for those interested is that this
door behind me is a washroom door i rent
a one bedroom
one washroom place now my wife
is we're in lockdown if this is ontario
so you can't
actually leave your home and for some
jobs you can't actually perform them
so my wife is home much of the time and
when i'm conducting these podcasts i
tell her
you have to stay in the room you can't
even get food to eat
get your water if you're gonna get food
just bring the food into the room
and if you have to use the washroom take
these empty cups
please because i can't have you come in
the background distract me
potentially interrupt the guests when
they're right at their most profound
point
and as well as she may be embarrassed
because she's wearing pajamas and so on
whatever one time i was
interviewing bernardo castro up and it
was supposed to be an hour to two hours
long i told her at most it's gonna be
two and a half hours just stay here babe
i love you
and then it ended up going for five
hours long now that was great for me
great for you great for bernardo we
didn't even notice the time went by you
can watch that interview it's one of the
best on the channel
but then i remember reeling from that
just shivering with the excitement and
and elated going into the bedroom
opening the door
the huge smile on my face and my wife
livid
seriously babe five hours she's holding
filled multiple filled cups okay i would
like
that for that to not happen so i was
speaking to phil shertok again
someone who runs the discordance helping
out with this channel he said kurt just
get a green screen i can lend you one
you put it here
you make it look like it's this
background and then she can come and go
i would like to invest in equipment and
gear
like that so that's another reason why
i'm hoping for this patreon to grow
lastly these podcasts take days and days
and days to prep for sometimes weeks ian
mcgill chris
took weeks thomas campbell took took
months actually now i have stephen
wolfram coming up
and i have chris langan coming up who is
the person with the highest iq in
america at least reportedly so
either way stephen wolfram has a theory
of physics that apparently derives the
standard model
and some non-standard general
relativistic models
which means i have to become familiar
with those before i become familiar with
stevens and that's taking some time
chris langan has a cognitive theoretic
model of the universe
and that's well it's abnormal and so it
it's difficult to wrap one's head around
and that takes quite a bit of time
chomsky is coming up at the end of the
month that's actually june 1st rupert
spiro is coming up and apparently his
philosophy
is so drastically different than the way
that i think i'm
i'm extremely analytical and he abjurs
the analytical
so i don't know how long that will take
for me to wrap my head around
and at the same time i always have an
icky slimy feeling
about promoting myself or even asking
people to go to the patreon
patreon patreon and support you can even
see it right there where i'm stumbling
over my words saying it
however some of the patreons patrons
already told me
kurt stop feeling like
you're selling something stop feeling
bad about it just tell people about it
i wouldn't have known about it if you
didn't advertise it once and
i'm happy to support so please let other
people know and so this is me doing that
the patreon and the paypal are huge
huge boons that help me consistently
produce podcasts of extremely
high quality with extremely high
technical depth
which is different than much of the
other podcasts that are out there which
at least in my opinion are watered down
now there's nothing wrong with being
watered down especially if you want to
get an overview of someone's
theories i watch them plenty but
paradoxically for me the more watered
down it is the more dry it is and if you
look at the comments
on this channel many of you agree and it
seems to indicate there's a huge craving
there's a huge huge craving for people
interested in the rec and
inner workings of a theory and this
isn't provided
almost anywhere else please go to
patreon.com
kerchaimongo if you'd like to support
thank you so much and enjoy this podcast
judging by some of the comments already
at least one commenter said that it's
like the 2021 version of
sam harris versus jordan peterson that
is to say it's bernardo castro and john
verveiki
links to both of their work are in the
description
thank you sometimes there's a time lag
and you want to interject but you're not
sure if it's going to sound rude
just raise your finger like this the
other person will see and i may do this
you may do this
if you feel like you're looking rude
don't worry it'll look rude for the live
stream at the most but i'll take it out
when i finally edit it together i'll
just put the other person's face you
don't see
hopefully hopefully we cannot be rude
that'd be good
choose the finger wisely
yeah i don't know i mean i have to say i
ha suffer from high blood pressure so i
take diuretics
also from my meniere's i don't know if i
can go like three hours without going to
the bathroom i'll try
i haven't had much to drink this morning
but i want to forewarn i can't guarantee
that because
you mean go to the water you can have a
cup in front of you too if you need to
[Laughter]
while someone else is speaking the
trickle may then
turn the camera to you the jig is up
this one is an experimental podcast
because
usually what i do is i do a prodigious
amount of research beforehand
and ask guests precise questions but
this time i thought
how about i get two people on and have
them get to know one another which
usually happens behind
the closed doors of academia and have
these two titans the
people who are at the top of their
respective academic game speak to one
another
converse jovially instead of trying to
critique and debate
and and watch them get to know
get familiar with one another's ideas
that's the whole point of this
i'm taking much more of a backseat than
i usually
would take and i'm just facilitating
questions between you both
how does that sound okay let's see how
it goes
i'm kurt jaymungal a filmmaker and i run
the theories of everything podcast
i have a background in math and physics
which is why i'm interested in
theories of everything and theories of
everything
to me don't just include grand
unification but also
philosophical world views which is why
jonathan and bernardo
are here jonathan the great john
vervicky is a professor of the
university of toronto
in cognitive science and i believe he's
the only professor
that has a cognitive science course on
buddhism mindfulness and wisdom
in 2012 he gained
an award called the ranjini gauche
excellence in teaching
award and there are many more accolades
i can say for
john but i'll save that because he's a
towering figure and that would take
quite some time bernardo castro has a
phd in both computer science and
philosophy
the latter of which is what we're
interested in today
his work leads the modern renaissance of
metaphysical idealism the notion that
reality is essentially
mental i respect both of you greatly and
i want you to know that
both the bernardo interview on the
channel the theories of everything
channel and
john your interview on the theories of
everything channel are some of
the highest rated if not the highest
rated of all the interviews and i still
get comments to this day saying that
it's not only the best on the channel
but maybe the best interviews with you
so i
am so honored that you gave your time
and that
that happened thank you so much thank
you fantastic to know that
resonating so well it's great to be here
kurt it's been a while and it's good to
see you again it's a pleasure to meet
you bernardo
my pleasure john okay
just so you know the audience for this
podcast is generally
colossally clever so if you have to use
abstruce terminology that you don't
think
ordinarily people would understand it's
okay speak as if you're behind the
academic doors this is what
this is it's an experiment and if you
have to make logical deductive steps
quickly go ahead do so it doesn't matter
people can rewind people can pause i'll
start with philosophically how would you
all
john how would you describe yourself so
there's obviously isms like you're a
realist you're
a logical positivist you're a
materialist whatever it may be why don't
you
give the audience an idea as to where
you're coming from and then bernardo
you'll do the same um
sure uh if you want my metaphysical
stance i don't know if that's the most
important aspect of my work but
maybe that's the arena we're playing in
right now um
so i would describe myself as a
naturalist and to try and make that
clear
i reject uh the term that people often
apply to me materialist
i don't think that all of reality is
just matter
i don't i don't know um i don't know if
i know anybody who actually takes that
stance
and so you know like most physicalists i
think that we have to talk about
other real entities like time space
cause
um structural functional organizations
of things information etc and i think
they're all good arguments for that
and then i'm not i'm a non-reductive
physicalist which means
um i think there's genuine emergence um
i actually um sort of sort of
heretically i think there's also
emanation as well as emergence
but that we could get into that later
and
what i mean by that is i don't think
it's fair to say
or correct to say that the only thing
that really exists is the very bottom
level of our ontology maybe
quantum probability waves or something
like that i think that
this level at which we do science must
really exist for us
for science to really exist and for us
to draw the conclusions about the
reference of science such as
conclusions about the quantum domain or
the or or the
the relativistic domain so that's why i
call myself a naturalist
so a naturalist says that the ontology
is going to be consistent
with the natural sciences uh biology
chemistry
physics um and perhaps uh hopefully down
the road cognitive science
but it is not going to be reducible to
them and so it's a
it's a it's a quite uh layered and rich
ontology and then within it um
i happen to hold a position called deep
continuity
which means this is from work by
francisco varela evan thompson
a lot of people in what's called 4e
cognitive science or third wave
cognitive science
there's a deep continuity between the
principles that regulate
and generate cognition and consciousness
and those that regulate and generate
living systems
so i i take it after a lot of argument
that in order to be a cognitive thing
you have to also be a living thing
um and then and then there is also deep
continuity between living things that
are auto-poetic self-making
and self-organizing systems like
tornadoes and
eddies within streams and things like
that um
so it's a naturalism with deep
continuity
is um for me
the ontology that i think um uh
i find was plausible convergent and the
one that best helps to explain how
science itself is possible
um and so it's a it's also an ontology
that's deeply influenced
by neoplatonism because neoplatonism
tends to
emphasize building your ontology off the
the prima facie
datum from which you try to build your
ontology is intelligibility
uh the existence of intelligibility uh
which is
presupposed by science so i think that's
it
i hope that was not too course of a
nutshell but that's where
that's where i come from bernardo
i think like john i'm a naturalist as
well
whatever is not part of nature even if
it exists
it escapes so much the realm of what is
relevant
that may not be interesting to look at
it
unlike john i am a reductionist
i'm probably an extreme reductionist and
the reason i am that
is i think there are very fundamental
even insoluble problems
that you face if your reduction base has
more than one thing
because then you get you run into the
interaction problem
you have issues of parsimony that you
really need to postulate
many things in your reduction base and
large reduction bases
they don't explain anything they just
avoid the need for explanation by just
pronouncing
a number of things to be primitives uh
dispensing with explanation
so i am a reductionist even though my re
the one element in my reduction base is
different from
the elements in the reduction base of
mainstream materialism today
uh today i think the mainstream view
would be that
all quantum fields are part of the
reduction base
there is yet no unified feud theory so
we have a reduction base with multiple
feuds now i i don't go for that
i am critical of strong emergence
i think what we might call
a weak emergence what what david
chalmers calls a weak emergence
obviously exists sand dunes emerge
out of sand grains and wind
so we know that these things happen ice
crystals emerge
out of water and temperature variations
but strong emergence as an explanation
for instance for
how how phenomenal consciousness could
arise
from arrangements of matter
i think at best it's an appeal
to a complete unknown and and probably
it's a flat-out appeal
to magic it's a way to put a label on
something that
is actually incoherent uh we label it a
problem
and we say well one day we will explain
it but
we're just insisting on a path that is
leading nowhere
so to summarize it all my position is
what i like to call analytic idealism
it's an idealist philosophy that
postulates that at the bottom level of
nature there is only mind
not your mind alone not my mind alone
but only mind stuff
at the bottom of nature
and it's a mix between objective and
subjective idealism
i can go more into that to explain it
more later
um yeah that i think that
that summarizes it john what occurs to
you when you hear that
what questions pop up um
i guess the the the maybe there's a
question around the notion of strong
emergence
i'm actually proposing it depends what
you mean by strong emergence
i mean strong emergence is the claim
that there's not going to be any
explanatory relationship
between the levels i take it that what
we we say happens in weak emergence like
how water emerges out of
hydrogen and oxygen is because we have
have some account
um and so and then the idea is you know
differences of degree
if us if there are enough of them become
differences in kind um
because then you not only get water
emerging and then you get water
has a particular set of relationships to
organisms such that it's a nutrient
uh which and there's no such thing as a
nutrient in physics it
doesn't belong in the physics ontology
um things like that
and so i think the position that i'm
arguing for is
you know is a form of what would
technically be called weak emergence
because i do think there
is emerging no pun intended an ongoing
explanation
um so for example um
we used to have a position that looked
like strong emergence for life
vitalism most people in biology myself
included reject that because now we have
a very complicated
but nevertheless i think you could
rightly say
version of weak emergence of life from
inorganic material
and so and i think we're getting a
similar thing happening
uh with the weak emergence of
intelligence
out of non-intelligent things um and so
i think given the
explanatory base provided by living
things that weekly emerge
and intelligent things that weekly
emerge we have pretty much we need what
we need in order to
generate a lot of the theoretical
explanation for a lot of consciousness
which is where this um
hangs in namely that i think that we
many people
are already coming converging this is
some of the stuff i worked on
towards a weak emergence explanation of
the function of consciousness
that's becoming less problematic that
was even somewhat excluded in trauma's
distinction around the heart problem and
i think as we get a richer and richer
account of the functionality
we will get a richer and richer account
of the nature of consciousness the
phenomenal aspects of it
um so i i think i would ultimately say
that i'm not defending a strong
convergence position i'm defending a
very
um complicated but never the
complication isn't the issue here
um the issue is whether or not i'm
advocating for a non-explore
non-explanatory relationship in the
emergence um
now is there a degree to which this is
promissory
well everybody's position right now is
promissory because the only way we
wouldn't have a promissory position
is if we had our completed science which
so
what we have to ask about is is it a
plausible promise and of course
well we might uh likely disagree on that
uh but
um that's that that would be in my
initial response
john you have an articulated notion of
what it means to be plausible do you
mind explaining that first
yeah so this is some of the work i do
outside of these thorny issues of
ontology
um because i'm very interested in
um trying to uh under well to understand
understanding
and how understanding differs from
knowledge and
one of the differences is people
generally talk about
knowledge in terms of evidence that
justifies where in terms
where understanding is uh relevance uh
that basically signifies uh and there's
an important difference there and so
one way of understanding uh this is
uh to that when people have a particular
kind of understanding they give it a
normative status when they say
something's reasonable
or makes good sense or they'll even say
it's plausible and they don't mean it as
a synonym for probable
it just means it may oh it's reasonable
that makes good sense that you know
and so when you take a look at what's
going on there there seems to be a bunch
of factors
this is based on a lot of other people's
work on plausibility and i won't try and
cite a lot of people here
for brevity's sake uh one is that we
uh with the idea that we want a lot of
independent
lines of converging evidence um
the idea being here this gives what
russia calls trustworthiness
if my particular theoretical construct
comes out of independent lines of
argument and evidence
that reduces the chance that it was
produced by theoretical bias or
empirical bias et cetera for example
that's why even infants
prefer information that is multi-sensory
so
they will they will give priority to
information that comes through
eyesight and hearing and touch then over
just eyesight
um you know ceteris paribus uh because
it's much more likely to be
real than a subjective illusion for
example so that's trustworthiness
you want your construct to have some
structural functional organization some
way in which it's structured
it's not just a list of features but a
way it has a structure
that indicates its function and then its
function of course is explicable in
terms of its structure
and then you want elegance you want that
that construct will map
into many new domains find problems
formulate problems that hasn't been
found before
and uh make them potentially
uh solvable so this is sort of elegance
so you have convergence
into something like a cognitive optimal
grip
elegance out and then you want to
balance between them
so if you propose something that will
explain a lot of things and looks
elegant
but isn't very trustworthy well that's
when something's far-fetched
you can have the opposite you can have
something that's very trustworthy but
has no elegance to it and that's trivial
and then you can do various kinds of
slips between them you can do
what then it calls a dpd where you
equivocate or you can do a martin bailey
thing
so when i'm talking about plausibility
i'm talking about a
a standard we have to use we can't
rely on because for example um i can't
test all possible hypotheses
the number the logical number of those
is indefinitely large
so if i'm a scientist i have to select
the plausible ones
and then when i'm testing it i have to
control for confounds do i control for
all possible alternative explanations
no that's impossible that's
combinatorial explosive so i select the
plausible ones that i control for
then i get my data and i have to drive
my interpretations from it
do i derive all logically possible
implications no that's combinatorial
explosive
so i have to i make use of the most
plausible
um implications so plausibility is
before during and after empirical
investigation
so it's irremovable now the thing about
it is it is
it's pragmatic it's feasible uh because
what it does
is it just gives you the normativity of
taking something seriously
we have that's not a sufficient
normativity for a knowledge claim
but it is a necessary normativity for
getting
your knowledge acquisition processes
going that's what i mean by plausibility
bernardo i'm sure thoughts present
themselves to you oh there's a lot to
comment on
um look i think um there is a heart
of objectivity in our notion in the
concept of plausibility
and i think john has elaborated on it uh
very well
but in practice a lot of what we call
plausibility
is a psychosocial phenomenon why because
the interpretation of data is is never
neutral
i mean we know that from from thomas
kuhn that the
very interpretation of data is already
paradigm laden or theory
laden if you look at the history of
science there was a point a couple of
hundred years ago in which floyd
stone was perfectly plausible an
invisible elastic
substance that connected shaft to an
ember
rod and accounted for what we today call
electrostatic attraction there was a
point in time in which newton's
gravitational force an invisible force
that
acted instantly and at a distance
between bodies celestial bodies was
considered
utterly implausible in fact in france it
took like 50 years for the french to
stop
laughing at newton
and then later on we figured that we can
laugh at newton again because there
is no such invisible force it's the the
fabric of space-time that
bends and curves and accounts then for
what we call gravitation
so plausibility i think it's something
we have to take with a grain of salt
because it is culturally
manufacturable and we have been
manufacturing plausibility
at the highest rate in history lately
for instance we are very busy
in the mainstream media manufacturing
floozability
for the outright incoherent notion that
you can
upload your consciousness into a
computer which betrays all kinds of
misunderstandings of
about computers and about consciousness
and neuroscience an outright ridiculous
idea
that now a lot of highly educated people
with phds
consider plausible because our cultural
milieu
renders it to us as if it were
plausible and since knowledge is now so
broad that every single person can only
know a tiny bit of what there is to know
we buy into it it's very difficult to
have an overview of all the salient and
relevant aspects of knowledge
to pass judgment on that so i would be
careful with plausibility in science
already but when it comes to
consciousness you know
it's not just science because science is
a study of nature's behavior
not a study of what nature is in and of
itself
what nature is i would say is irrelevant
to science because science makes
predictions about how nature will behave
what
what an experiment confirms or disproves
is the behavioral predictions of a
certain model
of nature's behavior and that's what
experiment
answers experiments produces an answer
in the form of a certain thing that
nature
does a certain behavior now of course
if you have a metaphysics a theory of
what nature is
that makes itself predictions that are
contradicted by science then you have to
discard that metaphysics so science
informs philosophy or metaphysics
but it doesn't settle philosophical
questions and when it comes to
consciousness i don't think it settles
the question at all
i think what's happening today is
we think that um strong emergence
is a plausible account for consciousness
because this notion has been culturally
manufactured it's not grounded in
objective reasoning or evidence
um because i think what happened at
first was that
scientists started from where we all
start from conscious experience
the experience of the world out there
the colors the melodies the flavors the
scents
that are around us and then they figured
out that it was very useful
to model those qualities conscious
qualities of the world
with numbers which could then be tied up
in equations
and and that was very useful to describe
the world so
carrying a heavy piece of luggage is
described with
50 kilos and holding a feather is
described with
50 grams and now you have a quantitative
way of dealing with these
relative differences and and making
predictive models in the form of
equations that relate all these
quantities together these are all
descriptions of the qualities
but at some point something very strange
happened around the time of the cards
and the conflict between science and the
church and that attempt to find space
for both
without the church having to burn
scientists alive
the question was sort of settled by
saying okay there is
uh mind the mental sphere
that's for the church and then the
church was very happy because from the
church
church perspective that was all that
existed right
and then we said and the descriptions
now
are not only a description of the
contents of mind
the descriptions exist in and of
themselves and moreover they precede
the contents of mind and that's when the
conceptual idea of
matter arose we said that those kilos
hertz you know length
weight or spin momentum electric charge
mass amplitude frequency we said those
things
aren't just descriptions those things
have standalone existence and they
somehow generate the world of experience
the colors we see the scents with you
it's like trying to pull the terror
the territory out of the map because you
know we have the territory
we described it we created the map and
then we said the map
precedes the territory it exists before
the territory
the description exists before the thing
described first incoherent move
second incoherent move somehow
consciousness the qualities of
experience
arise out of that it's like pulling the
territory
out of the map and then we face an
insoluble problem the heart problem of
consciousness
but because we've manufactured now a
century and a half
of plausibility for this idea that
matter precedes consciousness
we instead of realizing that the heart
problem of consciousness is not a
problem at all it's a reduction to
absurdity of the materialist postulates
it's just incoherent
the message is backtrack try another
another path because this one goes
nowhere
instead of admitting that we don't throw
away a century and a half of
manufactured plausibility
we label it a problem and we say one day
we will solve it and we call it strong
emergency or whatever one day we will
account
for it in order to
sort of preserve what we've built
so far okay john
first do you mind recapitulating what
your understanding of what bernardo said
is and then seeing if it matches
um i think there's a difference between
how i was trying to use plausibility and
he is i'm not equating plausibility to
every claim to plausibility
any more than i would clay uh you know
equate the claim to validity to validity
many people claim things are plausible
for reasons that bernardo
rightly pointed out we have a particular
paradigm but i would point out that what
he's offering to challenge that is a
plausibility argument
he can't make it one of deductive
certainty uh we sort of given up on the
idea that we can produce
a deductively certain metaphysics at
least as far as i can tell
um and so he's doing what he's doing is
presenting any
and he's good at it i'm not denying that
he's good at presenting something that's
very reasonable he draws independent
lines of argument and
independent lines of evidence together
so i'm talking about plausibility in the
normative sense i'm not talking about it
and what's simply what people claim and
what i'm claiming is in that normative
sense that's ultimately what we have
this is
sort of a pragmatist stance um and the
fact
that and he's invoking it lawden's you
know
pessimistic history of science right
shows that most of our theories turn out
to be false so it couldn't have been
truth that was guiding us it had to be
something like
plausibility and probability that were
guiding us and that's what
i think we should we should sort of say
we're doing
um now that doesn't mean that i don't
think he's not offering a plausible
argument i'm not saying that
i'm so i i understand that we should
periodically step back and criticize
our paradigms um but i would point out
to him that that means there's something
we appeal to above and beyond
our paradigmatic standards in order to
make such challenges
and hopefully get them understood and
accepted
i i reject i don't know if he does too i
reject sort of
a pure cunying response that is just
happenstance
and historical circumstance why you know
people adopt new positions i do think
they do something
that is trans-paradigmatic um but i
don't think it's cartesian certainty
because i've never been convinced that
such a thing exists so that's what i'm
trying to invoke when i'm invoking
plausibility
um i think and i think metaphysics and
i think even philosophy at large is the
art of disciplined
and you know and justifiable
plausibility something like that
so there uh that that's that um now
um i don't know what to do about some of
the historical because bernard said a
lot
um i happen to think that the
the the point he's pointing to happens a
lot earlier i think it happens around
scottish
yes yes from now on from this point
forward i'm going to take
oh wait wait wait wait did you see it
i'm i'm very curious about
your point about scottish i would like
to to continue to hear
you're bringing that back to the what
10th century ninth century no no no no
no scotus
uh is post aquinas so we're talking like
the 13th 14th century we're talking
about status and akam
that's where i think the change is made
because what happens with scotus is you
have the idea of the universe
the being is univocal that whenever we
say being we're saying this
it's the same for everything and that
sort of
demolishes platonic realism uh well
demolishes if you think scotus is right
and then occam's nominalism uh uh uh
brings out the idea that there aren't
any actual structures in reality
uh uh because all that really exists are
bear particulars bare individuals
and i think that's what severs uh the
idea
that there is something it destroys the
con
the conformity theory that there is
something identical uh
in being between between the knower and
the knowing
so uh you know the the the idea is when
i know something
in the older theory that there is some
shared structural functional
organization in my mind
and the thing that is constitutive of
the reality of the thing and so
there is a con and i think it's with
scotus
and with arkham and then you get the
idea of knowledge not as a conforming to
reality
but as coherence of propositions held
somewhere inside
and i think that starts the severing in
an important way and so i think
the important move is you know
a shift out of what i think
i think is plausible to say you know
ancient realism
ancient philosophy right up until and
including aquinas is ultimately
realistic
in its notion um and i think the
severing from realism
precedes the emergence of matter as a
substantial thing
um and so i i that's where i would start
to talk about uh
where the main issues are um
now i think what you're talking about
does happen with with descartes but
it's also prefigured and made possible
uh by you know the ideas of individual
conscience uh with luther and things
like that
separate and give a kind of internal
authority
uh separate from you know demands placed
on you by an external authority whether
that's the
whether that's the real world or god so
i think there's a
there's a sequence of stages that unfold
and i think that
and i think the issue about
consciousness is down the road
uh downstream from these earlier uh sort
of decisions about
well realism versus versus something
like
um uh i don't know what to call it
initially but it you know because it's
normalism
uh which is a minimalized realism and
then
uh and then you get a flat ontology with
scotus
because all the all the idea of real
differences in being
disappear um and so and that and the
and the and the irony of that is
um if you
if you posit any kind of reductionism
you are actually invoking levels of
being again
um and saying things like there are more
real levels than other levels
which actually undermines the scottish
position that started the whole
transition
in a powerful way so we're actually in a
really i think
within this paradigm if you'll allow me
we're actually in a kind of incoherent
place
where we want to say we want to we we're
holding to a view that came out of the
idea
that there there's no real differences
in levels of being but are now we are we
are moving towards positions
in which differences of being are taken
to be
sort of you know a plausible thing so
people will regularly say things like
well tables don't really exist and you
know all this
you know love doesn't really exist all
that's at the bottom and so
that's to invoke um a platonic
distinction
between levels of being and so we we're
actually in an incoherent place
with respect to our notion of being i
would argue right now
okay when i said that i'm going to take
a back seat what i mean is
no longer from this point forward john
do you refer to bernardo as he because
that means you're talking to me about
bernardo you just say you because now
you're speaking to bernardo and
bernardo's same
so now you say you so john so-and-so
bernardo take it away and john if you
need to interject you go ahead
right john there are many points i think
that we have in common based on what you
just said i'm
trying to make a mental list of those
points um
i'm not for total relativism either
i think there are good objective
epistemic
criteria and that we can follow in order
to have
a higher degree of certainty or a
lower degree of uncertainty about our
postulates
and inferences i would go as far as to
submit to you that um kuhn himself
wasn't
a relativist in the way he's often
portrayed to be and he was very
frustrated in fact for the fact that
he was portrayed uh and that way
yeah i refer you to an interview done uh
with uh with the [ __ ] by my friend john
horgan from scientific american back in
96 i think um
one in the final years of of kun's life
um another thing that that i think we
have in common is that um
i'm not postulates that we can have
inferential certainty here
um i don't think you know apes evolved
on planet
planet earth uh in in a corner of a
typical galaxy somewhere in the universe
have the cognitive apparatus to capture
with
certainty this alien aspect of what's
going on
of course not reality is filtered
through our cognition
and our cognition has evolved to allow
us to escape tigers and find fruit
and hunt bison that's basically what we
evolved to do
even our symbolic thinking is what 30 50
000 years old i mean to characterize
this as the blink of an
e of a nine the history of the earth is
to is to
vastly overestimate the amount of time
since we've
evolved uh that capability um
and third i also think
that um there are guidelines
that are more or less uh objective uh
i'm not sort of
surrendering surrendering everything to
paragmat
paradigmatic subjectivity
the role you attribute to a
more objective notion of plausibility i
would attribute to conceptual parsimony
because it's countable you know how many
different kinds of things are you
postulating to account for
observations and and although it's not
written or etched in stone in nature
that the best explanation is always the
most conceptually parsimonious
it may not be if we abandon
parsimony as an epistemic guideline we
open the doors to all kinds of nonsense
for instance there is an example i often
like to use if i wake
up in the morning and i see strange
footprints in my backyard
i can offer two explanations explanation
a a burglar went around
checked my door figured that it's well
secure and gave up and went away
explanation two aliens landed on my
neighbor's backyard
stole his shoes came for a stroll in my
backyard
left the footprints behind went back
boarded their spaceship in
and flew back to the pleiades now
neither
theory can be disproved on the basis of
the data available
both account for the data but one
postulates a lot less than the other one
postulates a burglar
a human being of the kind we know exists
the other postulates spaceships
alien races uh illogical strokes
uh illogical shoe robbery
so if if we abandon parsimony
um because we know it's not etched in
stone if we abandon that
we are lost so i think that's one
one fairly objective criterion for
for guiding our epistemology if you
start postulating
too many things and interactions between
too many things or
appealing to too many unknowns it it
doesn't go
anywhere or it's not reliable
now finally uh regarding the question of
consciousness
you said um we would
always have to have a promissory
theory when it comes to consciousness i
would submit to you that that's
only true if you're trying to reduce
consciousness to something that isn't
consciousness then whatever theory you
come up will be promissory because we
have no idea how that reduction can take
place that's why we talk about
strong emergency it's a way to not have
to make the reduction explicit but you
see
every theory of nature needs to have at
least one thing in the reduction base
you can't explain one thing in terms of
another forever
otherwise eventually you go back the
question your reasoning will be circular
at some point
so you have to always have that one
thing at least one thing in the
reduction base
for which you have no explanation in
other words
you can't explain that one thing in
terms of anything else
that can still be your best theory of
nature
because so long as you can explain
everything else in terms of that one
thing
then you're fine because you always need
at least one thing in the reduction base
i would offer to you that if you put
consciousness as the one thing in that
reduction base
you eliminate the heart problem of
consciousness because you're no longer
trying to reduce it the promissory notes
are off the table
your challenge now is to explain then
the
the phenomenality our phenomena
our inner phenomenal life and the
empirical observations of the world
outside which are always qualitative
ultimately
in terms of that one thing in the
reduction base
that is the challenge but then i would
submit to you that
that challenge is of a whole other level
and character than trying to reduce
consciousness
it entails no hard problems it entails
no appeals to unknowns you can do that
by using phenomena that you already
know occur in nature
so i think it's much more promising to
go that way and then there is no
promissory notes
so i would respond to that i mean
parsimony is a difficult thing
i mean it depends on how you individuate
your entities
and there's no canonical way of
individuating entities
and the attempt to find conceptual
primitives i think has been a largely
failed project
so i at the number of entities depend on
it
right how i individuate them is
consciousness one thing or many things
how do you know that how do you
determine that and how do you determine
that in a reliable way
and and if you're talking about
reduction uh do you have one thing or do
you or
is everything an illusion above that one
thing
and then you do have a hard problem of
how is it we're doing science at these
illusory levels
to point to the bottom level but that
we're claiming is the only thing that
really exists and if you say well no i
don't mean they
don't they're all illusions they also
exist then i
posit to you that you do have a complex
ontology and you do have
multiple things i mean
so i don't even know what we're
referring to
when we're individuating this thing
you're calling consciousness
um is it one thing um i don't know i
mean
it seems to me that there's aspects of
my consciousness
that are um qualitative in nature
there's aspects of my uncon they're my
conscious life that seem to
require relationship to something that's
unconscious uh
my memories come and go i wake up i fall
asleep
um has there actually been one
consciousness through all this time
or multiple consciousnesses does my
consciousness disappear
i mean and i seem to be able to
have experiences where i i have sort of
a dual consciousness where i'm
i'm sort of aware of my own
consciousness but i'm aware of the world
as well is that one consciousness
or two i i mean and i'm not i'm not
trying to be obtuse here i i
i the invocation of parsimony it seems
to me
to is to i think it's really an
indication of elegance
uh because most people qualify even
occam did
parsimony is you reduce to the minimum
needed to generate
your explanation um and that depends
also as many people have pointed out
on how we individuate things right and
we can't make it syntactic
because all i can do is i can just
replace every relation with a higher
order noun
or a lower order noun you know is
baseball one thing or many things
how do we count it well it's made up
well it's made up of many people oh
so it's made up of oh media like whoa
what is a person one thing is
consciousness one thing
like so uh i think invoking the notion
of parsimony
is ultimately uh something that we do
heuristically and pragmatically i don't
think
we have an algorithmic formal account i
mean
the accounts that we have that approach
that like gol magorov
uh uh simplicity um uh proved to be
computationally impracticable
uh so they they can't be what we're
using when we invoke parsimony
uh and other than that i don't know any
formalization
of simplicity that isn't question making
um
now we all use it bernardo i'm not i'm
not denying that
but what i'm saying is i i think the the
appeal to it
as uh as an absolute
uh mythological principle that we it
just runs it
objectively i'm not convinced by that
argument
um now uh to the point about
consciousness again maybe maybe
and this is what i need to get is and i
i'm also conscious
pun intended uh that we're trying to
make this dialogical
i play we disagree and and and we have
to be honest about our disagreements
but i don't want to i don't want to come
off as like imperious
or i want to come off as receptive and
listening to you uh not i don't want to
come off i want to be that that's what i
aspire to
uh so um i'll try and
i'll try and i'll try and uh i'll try
and uh
live this as enthusiasm rather than
anything
aggressive or anything like that because
i don't want to be doing that you're um
so i'm not quite clear what you're
pointing to when you say
like let's take sort of a stand your
standard human thing
i'm actually not aware of my
consciousness
i'm aware of things consciously but i'm
not aware of a thing
an entity uh consciousness that's human
right there
hume versus sparkly yeah yeah yeah and
and the pro and
they're both empiricists they're they're
so that's why i'm doing that because
they they agree on the same
methodological principles as far as i
can tell
right um and so john give
sorry to interrupt john give let's have
some shorter
bursts of speech and then just hand off
to other other person maybe one question
or two questions and
two statements well actually very long
so maybe you should have a chance to
comment on everything i said well no i'm
really i'm willing to do i'll just make
those two points the points is
i think that um i think i i don't think
we actually ever go for simplicity i
think we go for elegance balance by
trustworthiness
um i think that and and that's uh um
so i think parsimony is is is a
problematic notion
um um but the interest of anything is
this
even more problematic because what is
trustworthy but
but but i i get your point um and so and
then my other point was
um uh since we are counting and a single
entity
uh there is a sort of you know the human
problems as well
uh are are we talk are we equating
experience to consciousness
because that's a problematic move um and
are you really making consciousness uh
like it seems to me you have a double in
consciousness
you have consciousness as experienced
and consciousness as experiencer
and therefore you're not actually
getting the one thing
at the bottom um and that and then
all of this over here because the here
is something that's not within conscious
but i'm inferring
i'm inferring it from my experience and
then if i'm willing to infer things
outside of my consciousness
well then why not be a realist that's i
guess that's what it sort of comes to
okay
um i will i want to start with a point
where i agree with you but uh just with
a preamble first
everything you said is directly
applicable as a criticism of physicalism
and any other ontology so you are not
sort of singling out idealism you're
criticizing your own position
uh with the arguments you you just put
on the table and there is one thing
where we agree and i think a lot of
people
miss on it our carving out
the world into things is purely
nominal there is no antique
criterion for saying the car ends here
and here begins the road or here
the river ends and the ocean begins we
we separate the universe into things out
of convenience
it's it's arbitrary and and nominal
because if you say well i would define a
car in terms of functionality
so if i need the spark plugs then for
the car to move
then the spark plugs spark spark plugs
are part of the car
well then you need the road because
without the road for the tires to grip
you don't move and you need the air to
enable combustion
and you need the gravity of the earth to
pull the car towards the road i mean
soon you have the entire universe and
now with with quantum entanglement
uh uh you literally have the entire
universe
so partitioning the inanimate universe
into things
is is completely nominal i do think we
have anontic criterium
for saying that we end here
like if you shoot a bullet through the
chair where i'm sitting i will not feel
it but if you shoot a bullet through my
belly i will feel it
if a photon hits my retina i see it if
it hits the wall behind me i don't see
it
so there is a antique criterium for
saying
here we as you know our inner lives can
be delimited in physical space
at the boundaries of our body and that's
not merely nominal it's not arbitrary
because in some in some cases i feel in
other cases i don't view
now um where do i want to go with this
i lost my train of thought where i was
going with this but it was very
important what uh what i wanted to tell
you
um john then do you want to step in okay
can you can you just uh summarize
briefly again
oh oh yeah i remember i remember um
the the idea of parsimony and and how do
you say
uh whether consciousness is more than
one thing and
and hume's critique uh of of barkley
so for the sake of the audience uh
barclay said well
everything is in the mind and hume's
critique was to ask
well what is the mind i'm not aware of a
mind i am aware of different
experiences so how can you can you pull
a psyche a mind the soul out of the
variety of experiences i have
and back in the day that seemed to have
been a strong enough
criticism back in the 18th century but
it misses out
on a very clear intuition that we all
have
although the qualities of experiences
can vary wildly
the quality of having a bellyache is
totally different from the quality of
falling in love
all these things are still qualitative
they are experiential they are not
theoretical abstractions they are not
something that can be exhaustively
described through quantities
or physical parameters they are
qualitative
so i would offer to you the following
definition of consciousness which
is consistent with the idea that
consciousness is the one
member of the reduction base mind
or consciousness which i will use
interchangeably
is that whose excitations are
experiences
and if you define it that way then there
is only the experiencer
and experiences are different patterns
of excitation
of the experiencer so
there is nothing to experience but the
experiencer
in the same sense that there is nothing
to a ripple but
the lake where it ripples we use
different words
because it's convenient in dialogue to
speak of ripples instead of patterns of
movement of the lake
but we have to keep in mind that all
along there is only the lake so hour
long there is only
subjectivity there is only the
experience sir
and experiences are just patterns of
excitation of the experiencer
this has another advantage which it
eliminates
any interaction problem between
experience and the experiencer
because there is no such a thing as an
experience outside
the experiencer there is only the
experiencer
um what is the experience here above and
beyond the set of experiences
like why are they not just an atomic
sequence of experiences
as a sequence of atomic experiences that
would lead you to all kinds of problems
for instance what binds these
experiences together
why do we have the inner feeling that
these experiences are being had by
us as a subjective point of view into a
field of phenomenality
right and so so i answer a problem
by inferring a relation right and
and then that relation and the
mechanisms by which that relation works
how things are bound together
is actually not something i'm
consciously aware of let me give you a
concrete example
i mean i'm hearing your words and i'm
getting ideas
out of that and that's binding them
together
into an integrated proposition in my
mind i have no idea how i'm doing that
my introspective awareness of that gives
me no account in fact
and any in common sense intuitions i
have have largely turned out to be wrong
so most of the processing that is
allowing me to do the binding is not a
processing within my consciousness
it's a processing that makes my
consciousness possible
right i mean that's the content argument
right the content argument is you
have to propose some sort of
transcendental binding but it's tr it's
precisely transcendental
you argue for it as that which grounds
and makes possible
the experience not as something that's
found within the experience
uh here this has a lot to do with one
point you made before
which is you said a lot of my conscious
experiences
seem to be anchored in something that is
not
uh consciousness something that's sort
of operating in the dark in the
background
i find that more generic criticism
to hold better than what you just said i
would say
how do you know that there is binding
well that binding is itself
an experience it is itself a pattern of
excitation of your subjectivity
that arises maybe as an interference and
wait but i i'm not asking how i know the
binding is there
i'm asking what it is that exists in
order to explain the binding
and those aren't the same thing right i
don't think the entity you're looking
for is necessary
the notion of binding is itself a
pattern of excitation of consciousness
because the binding so far as you can
speak of it
it is some kind of experience you're
having no no the binding
that so i have a conscious experience of
you making sense
but i don't have a conscious experience
of the binding of those sounds
into meaning that then make and you know
i i i and i like i have no conscious
experience of acquiring english
but here it is and i have it
right how is that bound to me right i i
want to answer
this but yeah i want i wanted to answer
a better example because i think here
you are looking for an
entity that doesn't need to be there i
think there is a very natural flow of
experience which we call
understanding but i agree with you that
you are appealing to a lot of background
stuff to enable that conscious binding
you're appealing to knowledge that
you've had before
and which is no longer in the screen of
your memory being relived
right now um and look there there is
over a hundred years 150 years now if
you count
far back enough of depth psychology
which sort of
has accumulated evidence for parts of
the psyche that we cannot report on
feelings that we have and we can't
report on memories that we have and we
can't report on
and which may lead to the notion that
okay there is something other than
consciousness
because if my consciousness is operating
on the basis of something that i can't
consciously report then there is
something other than consciousness
i would dispute that based on the modern
uh
differentiation between consciousness
and meta consciousness
between conscious experience and
conscious metacognition
i think what we report is an expression
of what we what we are metacognizant of
the contents of our meta consciousness
the experiences we have and know
that we have but in the background
uh stuff that we cannot report because
we don't know that we are experiencing
that stuff
it is still consciousness um and we have
everyday examples to show that you're
breathing right now you're always
conscious of your breathing but only
right now because i mentioned it
did you did you become meta conscious of
your breathing because you
placed your your attention on it you you
reflected that experience of breathing
so this stuff in the background that you
have
referred to i would say it's all
experiences which are not available to
your introspection right now for you to
report
because they are obfuscated by the
limited contents of your meta
consciousness
or they are dissociated or inferentially
isolated
we know dissociation exists and it's for
real since the advent of neuroimaging in
the 21st century
so i i i do think that hume's critique
of barkley
was a straw man because he wanted to
produce a
thing a psyche a soul you don't need
that all you need is a field of
subjectivity whose
excitations are our experiences and now
in the 21st century we now have
a century of examples in physics in
which we've done exactly that we've
reduced now
elementary subatomic particles to the
patterns of excitation of a quantum
field and going to m theory this is even
this even goes into the direction of
unification theory there's a there's an
enormous tradition about reducing things
towards
excitations of uh extended uh
um feuds so to say okay
john looks like he's bubbling with rage
so please not bubbling with rage
uh yeah let it all out john no i want to
get it all though because i i
want i want to make space uh so you're
dividing consciousness into meta
consciousness
and things in the background that i
can't get access to
because i currently don't have knowledge
and it sounds to me like you have parts
of
my consciousness that are not aware of
each other are not conscious of each
other
so again now you have a multiple entity
as far as i can see
ontologically is only one thing it's
common
but why because it's only one kind of
stuff and there are dynamisms within
this consciousness no
no no no we're not talking no no we're
not talking about just one kind of stuff
we're talking about the entity no no
we were talking about the number of
entities we propose
in our explanation in order to generate
our explanations
that's what we were talking about and
to say i'm proposing one kind of stuff
is to beg the question because then
you're invoking the parsimony
and that's the very thing that i'm
pointing to which is it seems to me
you're multiplying your entities in
order to try and generate your
explanation
as you should as you should i mean
because i deny that
i i thought by appealing to feuds i i
had to counter that but okay go ahead
okay but so you've got you've got
things in in my consciousness my
introspective consciousness that
i are nevertheless so there seems to be
distinction
there seems to be a distinction between
what's in my consciousness and what's
available to my consciousness via meta
consciousness
so mental consciousness must have a
functionality different than from the
rest of consciousness
to explain the fact that it's limited in
some fashion
yes yeah so in terms of the
functionality i can count different
things there yes no
no because why not consciousness and
meta consciousness
are both consciousness ontologically do
they operate the same way according to
the same principles and the same
functions
does an electron operate the same way as
a quark
both are parts of a field um so
yes you can have one thing manifest
different patterns of behavior or to
function in different ways
without requiring that thing to be many
things ontologically it's still one
thing with multiple different functions
what in a non-question begging manner
what makes it one thing
it's experiential but it's precisely not
because my meta consciousness can't
experience parts of my consciousness no
your meta consciousness cannot report
parts of your consciousness to yourself
but my point is exactly that what is not
reported is still experiential
just as your breathing is experiential
when you're not reporting to yourself i
am breathing
how is that different from your
experience being experiential
and i can't and i'm not aware of it
right now
i would postulate dissociation as
something that exists in nature
we not understand it fully well but we
know it exists and it could account for
the appearance of there being multiple
minds instead of one and
the study of dissociative identity
disorder now it's has advanced so much
that we know it's literally blinding
sure and and and but we we also have you
know accounts of the dissociation
um in terms of trauma i mean there's
serious disanalogies
but because notice what you tend to
invoke
when you do that you have now three
entities you have the meta consciousness
that can't report to myself
what's going on in my consciousness um
and that seems to me
to be and and that's the kind of
machinery you typically invoke
at least in the psychological
discussions of
right of dissociation like i get
dissociation from this part
of this part of my mind from this part
of my mind in order to protect myself
this part is protected from trauma from
that part etc
um and so it now sounds like you've got
meta consciousness that can't fully
report to the self
what's going on in consciousness both
our consciousness meta consciousness is
a particular configuration of
consciousness
what is the self it's reporting to it's
the one future
of subjectivity where all these
experiences are are happening
some of them are reflected and therefore
can be reported
other experiences are not reflected but
but i'm asking what is the reporting
going to if it's going back to the field
and better consciousness is in the field
why is why is medic consciousness
unaware of it because
it's not reporting to itself or what
all the patterns of excitation that are
happening in the field because it folds
in upon itself in such a way
that it focuses the ability to to focus
to
to to reflect on a subset of what's
going on
and that's presumably very important for
survival
so it's reporting to itself that it
doesn't have
everything is that but
it's not reporting to itself some of the
experiences
it is having i mean from psychology we
know this happens i mean we
don't need to go very far especially men
are not
able to report even to themselves a lot
of the emotions that they are actually
have and
having and which is impacting their
behavior i mean therapy rooms world
the world over are featured
okay let's turn this into a therapy room
for a second
right now we're talking about the
disagreements and in previous podcasts
what i like to refer to is something
called theomaki which is a battle of the
gods
and it's tongue-in-cheek because
obviously you're not gods but
intellectually you're intellectually
used you're
let's say mini demons whatever you want
to call it
and so i like to say that this is theo
maki and i wanted this to be more of a
theolocution
in fact i was going to coin that term
because you have dialogues for vicky
sure this is theolocution and
i don't care if it turns into theomaki
it's actually entertaining much like the
debate that was about truth between sam
harris and
peterson and maybe this is going to
become one of those where we hammer down
specifically onto one instead of the
broad array of subjects
which i don't mind so to turn it into a
bit of a therapeutic session
why don't you first each say something
about the other's point of view that you
agree with or find interesting and then
you can go and battle it out once more
uh well i mean i think we are battling
it out precisely because
we are respecting each other and we're
trying to do science
and the problem here is science is a
little bit different configured
i mean science intensive sciences uh not
in the sense of just empirical science
that we're trying to do science here and
and therefore
uh we we we're doing the the kind of
thing you do in science which is pit
arguments and evidence against each
other
um and and and
and and i think that's sort of
appropriate within the scientific
discourse
uh if we move to more you know
existentially encompassing issues
i think then we we shouldn't stay in the
in the realm of debate
uh we should move into dear logos um
there's a lot i respect first of all uh
i wouldn't be giving my time
and effort to and this is not meant to
be left-handed
to bernardo if i didn't think he was
articulating his position very well
and so i i do want to acknowledge that
and i
i do think that there is
i would agree with him i hope this is
comes off as
uh an appropriate compliment i think
most of the versions of materialism
that are prevalent even within
some of the cognitive science community
especially within neuroscience
neuroscientists for example
uh the vast majority of them uh adopt uh
you know a strong identity theory that i
think would just be devastated by the
kinds of arguments
that bernardo is bringing up and so
that's why i don't eat that that's
because of the sophistication of these
arguments
and and their plausibility i'll use that
if you'll allow me
uh that i think uh any a hard-line
materialism like that is not a viable
position
um so i like that about what he's doing
i like that he is
um trying to give a
larger place to our phenomenology
uh then is typically given in a lot of
the analytic discourse
around consciousness and the mind-body
problem and that's a bit of a disjunct
between the continental
and the anglo-american tradition and i
like that that's why i've been trying to
shift into the phenomenological
with him right now and play there
because i think that's a
i think that's important and
so that's those are two two or three
things i really like i like the rigor
um i think the arguments against many
versions
and again this isn't a trivial thing to
say i just pointed out that
many neuroscientists i think adopt the
position that his
his arguments would be very cutting
against and i want to acknowledge that
and i think that's important and to to
not say that's important i think is
disingenuous
and i do like the fact that he
is trying to bridge between the
continental and the anglo-american
tradition by integrating an analytic
argument with much tighter
phenomenological investigation
i think that's all those are i think
methodologically that's a very important
thing to do
bernardo and i don't have anything
against heated debate in the least that
is that
actually what goes on behind closed
doors and academia and i
no but i want i just want to thank you
for doing that i i mean i think it's
i think it's important to to
periodically do what you just did which
is to step back and regroup
and see what i mean it's it's it's a
sterile thing if we're not capable of
listening and potentially learning from
each other
okay so bernardo well
i think uh john's focus
on what he calls the meaning crisis is
the single most important
and most devastating problem and that we
as a species
have today and by highlighting that
and and offering fairly practical ways
of
addressing that problem avenues for
trying to get out of it
by restoring the role of myth uh by
taking
our phenomenology our experiential world
seriously and not dismissing it as just
an epic phenomenon
i think that attempt to solve the
biggest problem we face today as a
species
that alone makes him and his work one of
the most important people alive today i
think
well thank you bernardo that's very high
praise um
um it's precisely because i suck on that
i think many of the people in the chat
second that but they would also
credit you with that too bernardo i i
yeah i i wanted to i wanted to return
the compliment i think
trying to get we i think we agree on
this we may not agree where we end but
we agreed that
the meeting crisis is not going to be
solved at sort of the political
uh market level it's it it goes down to
our fundamental ontology
and it deals with fundamental aspects of
our ontology like subjectivity and
objectivity
and that how how meaning is somehow
bound up with those
um and of the sense of self and i think
we agree on that
uh it seems to me we agree on that and
you're nodding so
yeah and so i think uh in in that sense
we're both
very critical of um a lot of
what i think are misplaced
and sometimes distracting attempts
to deal with the meaning crisis uh that
do not wrestle
with these deep problems i'm not i'm not
saying i don't think bernardo's saying
everybody has to be
you know an academic philosopher to
wrestle with the meaning crisis
but i do think if we want to
if we want to hone whatever ecologies
and practices we come up with to address
the meeting crisis
into a world view we have to do
something to our current world view to
get us to the place
where we have a world view that can
properly home
rehome the the ecologies and practices
and the experience of sacredness
and i think in that we also agree i am
so i want to be i want to be clear about
something here
um um i i i'm not happy
i i thought i said this but i don't
think i emphasize i'm not i'm not trying
to countenance sort of the standard
scientific worldview model i'm willing
to uh
you know change my ontology quite a bit
i tried to convey that with
some of the things i've said and so i
think
the disagreement it might be more about
what are the changes
and how far should the changes go um so
um i think i think what bernardo's doing
is important and i do i
i would not want anything i'm saying
the to be taken as meaning people should
not
wrestle seriously with his work i don't
i'm not trying to imply that at all
neither neither continue i interpret to
you that way uh
john can i can i continue
please do okay look i do think
that um our mainstream ontology plays a
role in this and i don't think it's a
positive role but i'm also quick to
admit
that it is one role it's not the whole
story
there there are other things going on
and i think another enormous thing that
you point out
uh when you say that we over emphasize
propositional knowledge
knowledge of facts as distinct from
wisdom which is
very hard to define although you you
elaborate
extensively on how he actually can get a
grip on what wisdom is
but what is immediately clear is that it
entails a lot a lot more than
propositional
yes knowledge yes and we live in a
society
in which the people we
take direction from today the
spokespeople of science we see on
tv often um
they are and
sorry if i go too far in this
characterization but they are very often
psychically unbalanced um
one psychic function is taken as the
only one that matters
it's a kind of analytic rational
conceptual thinking and that is taken as
the only thing that is trustworthy
and they are challenged when it comes to
the richness of all the other psychic
functions
like intuition appreciation for art
sense
perception you know being grounded in
your senses as opposed to abstraction
um and and we don't see it we take them
as the new wise man and
uh and they are people who have large
chunks of the human psyche amputated
from them and they have become our wise
men i i call it um
the uh idolatry of nerds and the word
nerd is a is appropriate uh i think uh
to be used here
and i think it's tragic that we've been
trying to
replace wisdom with
pure extensive encyclopedic
propositional knowledge
as if the latter were a substitute for
the former
and as if doing this could be justified
immediately by the lack of
absolute uh certainty that
that you can attach to wisdom yeah
i think that's very well said uh what
you've said there bernardo
i agree um and i mean i've argued for it
extensively
um which is part of what i what i was it
was
trying to point to where i said i
appreciate you trying to bring in a
phenomenological richness
uh to this uh the discussion we were
previously engaged in
yeah i do think that the the recognition
of the significance and importance
um in two directions both
you know in terms of our ontology the
significance
of the non-propositional uh ways of
knowing and ways of being
in the psyche i think and then also the
the the increasing evidence
that it's though is those
non-propositional aspects of the psyche
and ways of knowing that contribute the
most to meaning
in a sense of meaning in life um and i
think
um that tyranny of the propositional or
the tyranny
the idolatry of the nerds um is not only
limiting our capacity to try and
understand these phenomena
and thereby create a world view to which
we can belong because we don't belong to
the current
current worldview that's i think
something we would also agree on i think
um
but also the the the just the fact that
it puts at
it puts individuals existentially um
at risk of of all of the deleterious
effects of suffering
a paucity of meaning in their life and
the symptomology of that i think
is very pervasive in our culture okay
let's get to the disagreements
again okay well i think we were talking
about the multiplicity of consciousness
or is it one well i just wanted to point
out though that
that um
and i think this is important this is
very much like an in-family kind of
disagreement
uh that i i i don't want to presume i
just met bernardo but uh
bernardo i would say to you uh you know
everything you're saying here
um leads me to really appreciate the
motivation you're bringing to these more
sort of technical ontological
disagreements we're having
and i want to i just wanted to express
that appreciation before we return
back to potential debates because i
think that's important i mean
for me um
sorry i don't want to make this sound
pragmatic one of the things not only not
the only thing obviously there's the
own internal epistemic success but one
of the things
that would could potentially move me
more towards your ontology
is if i could see how it might more
readily
address some of the difficulties that
i'm trying to address
with my ontology with respect to the
meeting crisis um
and so that be something perhaps we
could also discuss
uh somewhere along the way can you
mention
two or three uh concrete points
um so uh so one of the things
that i've been trying to
do and this was something that you
admitted in your ontology
and then i got i swear i noted it but i
sort of got sidetracked in
being uh heated i guess uh you would you
admitted sort of
even within consciousness processes of
of filtering um and you you probably
know that
at the core of my work on like
intelligence as
distinct from consciousness although i
think these ultimately are related has
to do with this issue that i call
relevance realization which is
of all of the information available to
me i can't
contin and right end up all the
information available to me in my memory
and of all the possible sequences of
operations that's also combinatorial
explosive so
yet moment by moment i'm somehow
realizing
focusing on what's relevant basically
intelligently ignoring and it's a
constitutive part of my intelligence
most of that information that is not any
algorithmic process
and it is also it is always prey
to the deleterious effects of the bias
so the various things that make me
adaptive at this make me subject to bias
the self-deception um and we have
moments where
that self-correction comes out when we
have aha moments and insight
and so i happen to think that
that that relevance realization
um is a way in which we're dynamically
coupled to the world
um i can give that argument in more
depth later but i'm just trying to give
it just here
and i think that's that that
that underwrites our cognitive agency
but
we also experience that connectedness as
deeply rewarding
and that reward is different from the
word of like of pleasure
it's the reward that we call meaning in
life which is also just different from
subjective well-being
and so i think our meaning in our that
sense that positive rewarding sense of
meaning in life and man will people do a
lot for meaning in life
they will set they will set they will
sacrifice a lot of pleasure and a lot of
contentment
in order to get meaning in life and they
reliably do that for example when they
have a kid
because pleasure and subjective
well-being go down dramatically
but meaning and life go up significantly
absolutely so
yeah so i thought i think that that
connectedness
is central uh to
uh into meeting in life and then i
i use basically an evolutionary model of
trying to explain what that
connectedness is like there's something
in our brain and
no that's the wrong way of putting it
there's something in the relationship
between the brain and the world
that is strongly analogous uh to
biological adaptation biological
adaptivity
and then there's something analogous to
how that evolves in a self-organizing
fashion
that we call intelligence and that helps
me to explain a lot of the progress i
see
within artificial intelligence a lot of
the convergence i see within cognitive
science and cognitive psychology
and so i tend to see that in that way
and i'm wondering
if well i want to make it a genuine
question
is there a way in which your ontology
would speak to that
in a way that might be uh particularly
helpful i mean i'm not trying to put you
in a corner if it doesn't
i'm not i'm not saying oh well there
it's false i'm not doing that it does
it's a it's an open question it does i
mean that's
my motivation for for doing what i do i
i i don't do this just because i want to
win
an academic argument in a world of
abstractions and
academic journals yeah i totally get
that yeah i do it because i think it
makes a difference
i mean we it's not even clear to us
anymore
that the story we tell ourselves about
what we are
and what the world is and our role in it
is the key source of meaning in our
lives why are we not aware of this
anymore
and i think that's because of fluid
compensation to use a
technical term in psychology we are
fluid compensating
all over the place we've replaced
authentic
sources of meaning with self-validation
with the idea of leaving work behind
that survives
us with differentiating ourselves as
part of an elite group
this happens a lot among scientists so
even if we adopt a worldview
that is flat and bleak as i would say
mainstream physicalism is not not
perhaps well certainly not your version
of physicalism
but the mainstream physicalist view that
consciousness doesn't even really exist
that is so flat and meaning draining and
bleak
but we don't notice that because we find
ways to fluid compensate and find other
sources of meaning i mean
when we killed god in the second half of
the 19th century we were
quick to erect another edifice of
meaning giving and and that has evolved
now and i'll link that to artificial
intelligence which you mentioned as well
that has evolved now into
singularitarianism
which is a purely physicalist religion
which postulates that if we
create a ai that can build a better
version of itself faster than we could
then that would uh accelerate the
evolution of ai
exponentially and then we would create a
de facto god
who would then take care of us and like
we take care of animals in a zoo
i mean that's the religious impulse uh
the search from meaning
right there we never abandoned that
search for meaning even though we fluid
compensate and we find sort of
decoy targets for it but if you ask me
honestly where do i think it went wrong
i think it went wrong the moment we
started telling ourselves and believing
that the world we see is all there is to
the story
that the world is its own meaning as
opposed to being
an image of something else deeper as
opposed to being
how the world as it is in itself
presents itself to us but
there is this extra dimension of depth
and meaning
the images that we call the world are
pointing to something
beyond themselves a point explain which
music meaning
sorry to interject can you explain what
you mean when you say the world is it
itself is meaning uh
today under physicalist anthology um
matter is all there is
so if you have a material world around
you
then there is no extra dimension of
depth to that world
that world is all there is so whatever
meaning
it has it is that meaning
because it's not pointing at anything
else it's not representing anything else
because it's all there is and this is a
notion
that is today called a naive realism in
philosophy
um we know from science and philosophy
that this
is absolutely and categorically wrong
because one evolution wouldn't have
given us
a transparent windscreen to see the
world as it actually is
evolution doesn't do that evolution
equips us to survive
so evolution would would have given us a
dashboard of dials not a transparent
windscreen into the world
we also know from hardcore neuroscience
that if our inner representational
states you know our perceptions
if those states mirrored the states of
the world as it is in itself
our inner states would be too dispersed
and we would basically dissolve into an
entropic soup
we wouldn't be able to maintain our
structural and dynamical integrity
so we have to encode the information we
have about
the world in an inferential manner in
order to maintain our physical integrity
so we know that the world as it is in
itself
is not what we see or even measure
through instrumentation
because even measurement follows the
paradigm
of perception we you have to see the
output of the measurement instrument
or you have to see a histogram on the
screen i mean when i was at cern that
was my life it was looking at histograms
and calling them particles
the world as it is in itself is not
available to our direct inspection
the only way to know it as it is in
itself is to be it
and kant already said that and
schopenhauer echoed that
um so if we recover
if we put back into our explicit meta
conscious awareness
that this is what's going on then the
world regains a a dimension of depth and
mystery
and your life in it now has a meaning
not only the world as it is in itself
is the ultimate meaning which you have
to interpret out of how the world
presents itself to you
out of the dials that you have that
evolution has given you
even your role in it is now mysterious
because you are in the world even though
you don't see it as it is in itself you
know that you
are in it uh and that dimension of
mystery and meaning i think is this so
losing contact with that dimension is
one of the key sources of the meaning
crisis
and one way to recover that is to take
myth myth seriously not literally
but seriously and we've lost the art of
knowing how to do this
so i think that was fantastic and
beautifully said
uh yeah i think well i've already said
i'm a
i i think that flat ontologies
are incoherent theoretically and i think
they they make their adherence
engage in ongoing performative
contradiction uh all the time
uh in which like you said the scientist
espouses a meaningless universe as he
desperate or he or she desperately tries
to climb to the top of whatever status
hierarchy they belong to
and that's all kinds of performative
contradiction so i think there's
incoherence and there's performative
contradiction so
yeah i don't think that flat ontologies
um i i think are
are viable and then i think the idea of
recovering
i like what you said a depth dimension
uh to it
uh to our ontology is important
um so i i i tend to think
that that depth dimension comes in
when we invoke
well kind of what i was saying before
that like i'm sorry i'm just worried
about i don't want to
sound overly conscient because i don't i
i disagree with kant's idea that we have
no access
uh i disagree with that too by the way
but um yeah okay
yeah yeah okay thank you for that thank
you for that and so let's let
that so let's say we always have
filtered access or something like that
and and i think that that follows
directly i think that's something
that i uh i argue for and perhaps even
presuppose in the account of relevance
realization that i just
uh talked about by the way i would argue
this is the hardest pro
this is the hardest problem in
artificial intelligence almost as hard
as the heart problem of consciousness i
think relevance is a very hard problem
um and i do happen to think the two
problems are related and maybe we could
talk about that at some point
uh but um i do think that reality in
that sense
is other than it's the way see the
obviousness
of our experience is exactly what we
need to
explain rather than take as the basis
for our explanation
and i think by the time we've gotten to
the obviousness of experience
we've uh you know our brain mind and its
interaction with our brain body world
right interaction has has so
um filtered things that we have avoided
the combinatorially explosive nature of
reality itself
um and so that's why
and i've been trying to make an argument
and this is a bit of a side thing of
reconfiguring
the sense of what you call mystery and i
use that term
um i mean i i'm deeply influenced by
gabriel marcel's work on ontological
mystery
that a mystery is different from a in a
problem we frame it and then we can
bring clarity to it
in a mystery we find that the framing
itself is problematic and we keep doing
this
and right and we keep expanding the
frames and then we realize oh [ __ ]
it's bigger than i could possibly
accommodate and we get experiences of
awe
which are tremendously efficacious for
transforming individuals at the kind of
level
we're talking about conducive to the
cultivation of virtue and wisdom
um and doing experimental work on that
right now and so i
i i try to think and maybe this goes
back to some of the points i've made
earlier
i try to recon we conceive of that
mystery and sacredness not as completion
or perfection
uh because but as in sense as an
inexhaustibleness
there and so there's a bit of a
neoplatonic spin on this
there's an inexhaustible fountain of
intelligibility for us
um so we like as we uncover more
uh as uh right in the trajectory into
the mystery
it seems to have an underlying order to
it
an underlying pattern and
intelligibility to it which does not
it does not does not close off the fact
that there's going to be more that's
going to surprise us
and so i tend to think of the sacredness
as being exactly that horizon of
intelligibility
where we can look back and see all the
fields of intelligibility that have
arisen for us
but we have a tremendous sense of but
we're nowhere near and we'll never
be anywhere near exhausting this it's
kind of
it's kind of like what is is it
shellings the finite always longing for
the infinite
uh that's the sense of sacredness and
some of the early uh post continents
uh that's that's what i'm trying to
argue for now and i think
part of the thing that i'm critical of
of the cartesian paradigm which also
gets taken into
uh the the modernity of the
interpretation of religion
is this idea of certainty and completion
and closure
as the things that we are most seeking
and i don't think that is the case
i think that humans want i mean what we
know from
the meaning in life literatures human
beings want to be connected to something
larger than themselves
and to matter to it uh to fit to it
rather than have it fit to them
and so um sorry i've spoken too long
but that would be that's my attempt to
attempt to to say something i think
maybe convergent with you
young said uh the only important
question is whether we are related to
something infinite or not
and he nailed it yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
and the way we long for it and the way
that has a normative impact
on um the way we live our lives
and i think again we agree on this that
we are we are we both if you allow me to
speak for you
we're both sort of distressed by the
well i'll use it in the psychological
sense maybe maybe in your ontological
but the dissociation between the
worldview people espouse and believe in
and the way they're trying to live their
lives
and that disjunction comes that
dissociation
comes at terrible cost terrible costs i
mean
uh the uh and the way social media is
is uh doing exactly the opposite of what
it promised it's accelerating all of
this
rather than alleviating it any function
because it's not getting it
at the root of the problem there i'll be
quiet bernardo so you can say so
i can i can listen to you for a long
time because this subject is very close
to my heart i wanted to ask you a
question but
before i do that let's just a quick
clarification
um i i also am not with kant
that uh we can never have any sort of
access to the newman i think he went too
far
i think through perception we cannot
have access to the nominal
but the key insight that he missed and
schopenhauer added
uh very quickly after kant was that
we are our own numina
so through introspection i can't access
my numeral and since i'm part of the
world
i can make educated inferences about the
numina out there
because i'm also sort of material made
of matter at least as far as perception
goes
so if the matter in my body is the
representation of my will
then i can conclude the world as it is
in itself is also something like
the will so i think there is a channel
to the newman and that's introspection
and then that's what the world's
religious traditions have been saying
all along but the question i wanted to
ask you is this i i
i have some clinical psychologists
that i count as friends and we have
discussions
now and then and the subject that always
comes is
especially when you have a deaf
psychologist a psychologist oriented to
the depth as opposed to
behaviorism or anything like this or or
anyway
um the question i always ask is
if the task is to help your patient
recover
meaning can that be
done in the absence of a certain
ontological position
can you be ontologically neutral and
because psychologists talk about giving
meaning
uh maybe it's a literal translation from
dutch
but uh i think it works in english as
well how do you give meaning and
and and my feeling is that if if i am a
patient and i have done therapy by the
way
uh i i always come out of that with the
feeling it's like i'm trying to cheat
myself because either meaning is really
there
or it's not and my giving meaning to it
is some kind of
self-deception it doesn't work out for
me so do you think
we can solve the meaning crisis without
addressing ontology head-on
um so first of all i'm going to
i want to refund the first thing you
said as a way of preparing for my answer
the second thing
so i think the key and the most
foundational
the key to the most foundational kind of
knowing which i call participatory
knowing which i take
from ultimately inspired by plato um
but you but you can see it either you
can see it in all kinds of plateness and
i count young
as a platonus he's i think he's
basically the plato of the inner psyche
and the archetypes are the forums and i
think you could make a good argument for
that
um and that's why he was attracted to
neoplatonism and gnosticism
things like that that's that but that's
an exegetical claim uh but uh but
um right but it's this notion
and you and the reason why i think it's
important is i see convergence from
as you said other religious traditions
like so when i i'm
i i read a lot of the kyoto school
nishitani nishida
um uh masa abe uh you know
suzuki uh things like that and what was
going on there
and so the notion that comes out is like
from these two traditions and they
converge on this idea of uh
that unless you that at bottom
and i can make a more long argument for
this but i think you'll get the gist of
it
if i reject skepticism if i reject an
absolute skepticism i have to rely on
that kind of participatory knowing that
i i know it because i am it
right and that and because i am it and
that that part of the world
is also it uh we participate in the same
thing
that that is how that is how my mind and
the world touch
i know this might step on a couple of
your your toes but
that's my way of talking right now um
and so the idea that
um there's a kind of knowing that is
simultaneously how i know myself
and i don't mean my autobiography i mean
how i untickly and
even ontologically know myself that is
necessarily bound up with how i know the
world
when i see plato and i you know this
means i reject sort of standard academic
interpretations
of plato i see plato no no that's not
that's not true some
there's a growing group of people that
would agree with this interpretation of
plato so
um i see plato as basically the person
who sort of
proposed that uh that at the core of his
argument is that idea
of participation ultimately grounds us
and then that leads me to
you know um uh the the
the the the second point you asked do
you think we can address the meaning
crisis without fundamentally addressing
our ontology so there's there's two ways
of asking that question and since you
brought it up in the context of clinical
psychology it's important to
distinguish like i wouldn't want to
claim
that everybody has to do fundamental
ontology in order to get alleviation
uh from anxiety or despair or depression
or loneliness because they i would say
there's a level at which they they do
need an ecology of practices simply
changing their beliefs
is radically insufficient that's why
people go into therapy
many people i think live
live and this is not meant to be any
kind of elitist insult but they live
very pragmatically if they've got an
ecology of practices that's working
that's it that's good right
so in that sense i don't think everybody
has to do it but in the deeper sense
do they are they ultimately dependent on
scientists and philosophers finding a
way to ground
and legitimate that ecology of practices
in
a world view yeah i think they do
because i think our world view
this is deeply influenced by clifford
garrett's our world view is our
meta-meaning system
i'm not equating our world view
completely with our ontology
but i'm saying our world viewers are
sort of our our shared
our shared ontology our shared
commitment if you'll allow me that okay
and so and i think our world view is our
meta meaning system
it is that it is not itself a meeting
system it is that which
like you said at the bottom makes
possible all the other meaning systems
by
giving a participatory relationship a
pattern of co-identification
between the agents and what i call what
chris and i in our book
and philip what i call the agent in the
arena the world
becomes a place that is shaped
either physically or mentally to fit me
and by which i physically and that also
includes technology
and or mentally shape myself to the
world so that we
have a participatory relation so there
are our affordances
uh for behavior um and i think for me
it there has to be people out there
doing that there has to be people
who who are saying
the current worldview does not home us i
mean we don't belong in our worldview
we we like there's no place for us in it
and that means ultimately everything
we're doing
with our ecologies and practices doesn't
fit in that world view
and like i say most people don't have to
solve that problem but that problem
cannot remain unsolved
at least in the sense of seriously
plausibly addressed
so i hope that was an answer to your
question yeah yeah i i am with you i
i even agree with you and actually i
have
no problem admitting to this in
reinforcing this i don't think
any conceptual buy-in into a specific
ontology will
solve anybody's psychological problems
um
because conceptual understanding is not
embodied
it stays rotating somewhere in the head
and it doesn't go
down into your emotional life
i do think though that we are in a
culture where the the intellect is the
bouncer of the heart
so even if you could have excuse me did
you say bouncer like
like dancer yeah they get like at a bar
yeah yeah
that's right yeah that's a great
metaphor i love that
yeah the intellect is the bouncer of the
heart so even in situations where
somebody
would have a transformative experience
or a transformative insight
they don't give themselves intellectual
permission
to take it on board to even perceive it
let alone take it seriously and
and when the insight sort of muscles in
like the experience of
awe that occasionally we have
it comes in we have the ah but 15
minutes later saying yeah that's nothing
emotions are just a side effect of
evolutionarily
encoded behavioral patterns driven by
physiology
and off it goes it it doesn't sink in
so i i i think that although an ontology
would not solve the problem it
literally opens the door for whatever
solution
there might be because right now there
is a closed door and a
very big muscleful bouncer
at the door that's preventing us from
relating with more richness and depth to
ourselves in the world
i would agree with that bernardo uh
although i
i guess i think i think a bit a little
bit more like a bifurcation point
i think there are many people who do
exactly what you say the dismissive
distractive response
however i've met and you know even
within it within
an experimental paradigm because done
experiments on people with mystical
experience and
stuff like that i've met people who have
the opposite
so they have a very powerful and there's
literature to back me up on what i'm
saying they have these powerful
experiences
and they precisely can't dismiss them
there's something in
and so i call this onto normativity so
oft
like we people do dismiss many of their
altered states of consciousness and
again
that's adaptive and many of them should
be dismissed perhaps uh
but what's really interesting is people
and it looks to be about 30 to 40
percent of the population which is not
insignificant
have these experiences and they and they
do this they don't say oh it doesn't fit
in with this world view
therefore it's not real they do the
opposite they say that's really real
and therefore there's something wrong
with this
that happens too and that happened again
it's not majority but 30 to 40 percent
is not insignificant that's
that's a lot of people um and and
and and then and then but what typically
happens though is they
they go looking for some guidance and
they
can't find it and then they do an auto
didactic thing which can often spin off
in
very crazy things because precisely
there is no ontology
that seeks to bridge between if you'll
allow me everyday obviousness
and the kind those kinds of experiences
of awe
and like onto normativity like and what
and you know if you take a look at
jaden's work when people have these
experiences
they they will reconfigure their entire
lives their relationships their careers
even their sense of identity because
they want it and here's where i want to
invoke it
they want to conform more and more to to
that really real
the really real has an independent
normativity and value
to them above and beyond you know
practical power and
and so and they they do and they do
these these major transformations
but they're often thwarted or that can
go awry
precisely because they often have to do
it in a very auto
auto didactic fashion uh and that
you see and that's where i would hope
you know however
uh we managed to uh you know you know
flesh out the ontology
and make it work and i think we we
should both keep working
i would hope that it would
allow people to turn to individuals that
they pro
plausibly accord intellectual respect to
not because the project is intellectual
but because they can take seriously
the ontology that would allow them to
talk to each other
it would give them a lingua franca by
which they could
do what human do beings often need to do
which is to do this in distributed
cognition
not as isolated individuals so that
would be one of the hopes i would have
uh for an ontology that it one of my
hopes is that this distributed cognition
includes bernardo's cat
push off the screen okay
when i don't push him off he will
literally be on my face
what occurs to me is a question i'd like
you both to explore
that is what is real what exists how do
you define what exists and
can we ever know what's real
so bernardo why don't you start that
i don't think um apes evolved on planet
earth
have the cognitive apparatus
that would be necessary for us to know
uh conceptually the ultimate
salient truths of nature i don't think
that is possible
so i don't think the game we are playing
in ontology
is a game of finding what the truth is
i think the game is given our
limitations
in our best learnings and best practices
and our epistemic value system
how much closer to truth
can we get knowing that we will not
arrive
but can we do better than we are doing
right now
given what we know and our value system
but by value system i mean
our appreciation of of empirical
evidence our appreciation of internal
consistency
coherence uh of yeah i'll say that john
conceptual parsimony plausibility
so given this value system around which
there is
some degree of cultural consensus not
food
not full consensus but some degree of
cultural consensus
at least in academia how
well can we do can we do better than we
are doing now and
i i submit to you guys that i think we
can do
significantly better than we are doing
now that
that would not mean that we can get to
the truth of the matter
as apes evolved on planet earth
but we can get closer than we are and
and
by getting closer i also think and and
this is
uh not by construction it's it so
happens to be like that
by getting closer i think we will also
get healthier and we will leave in
a healthier way more aware of the depth
of the mystery
where we are inserted which is that
dimension of depth and mystery that
that we lose sight of today
that i think we can definitely achieve
now a quick observation i
i need to have a bio break shortly
so if we can find it you don't want to
take a fashion break right now
or maybe john can answer the same
question so there is uh yes yeah
yeah um okay so bye bernard we'll see
you right back
no i want to hear the answer and then i
hope we can yeah and then and then we
can both break
if possible um yeah so i mean
real can be used in two different ways
it can be used as an absolute
or it can be used as a comparative um
and i happen to think that it makes more
sense to treat it as a comparative
and i think that's what uh what you're
what you're saying bernardo i think
we although we can't say this is real in
an absolute sense
we can with good reason good evidence
and good
argument say but this is more real than
that
we can make those comparative judgments
uh in a way that
seems to be progressive uh in in the
sense that
like we can we we don't keep losing
previous claims
in some sort of chaos there's a slowly
building coherent structure
that emerges and we revise it and blah
blah blah blah not denying any of that
but i think i think the comparative
sense of realness
is something that we can uh we have to
and i think we can put our epistemic
trust in
um and and and so i think we that is to
say for all of our epistemic boundedness
i agree with you bernardo we are
we are we are slightly uh super evolved
apes that have
culture and culture ratchets which is
that's an important that's an important
difference
we don't we don't individually have to
relearn everything from scratch
and that does help but i think culture
ratchets precisely because
we can make this progressive improvement
i don't think there's any teleology or
anything like that i think we can go
we still could massively just screw this
all up nevertheless
i agree that we can get
we can get better and in a comparative
sense of saying this is more real than
that
and then this is more real than that and
then as soon as we do that
like again i think that means we're all
we are already committed to
a non-flat ontology um
and i think that as soon as we do that
we start drawing relationships of okay
this is dependent on this and this is
dependent on that
in terms of our judgment and i think for
me
that and this is where uh i'll i'll put
my neck out a little bit more perhaps
than bernard did
that's where to me again that original
sort of platonic insight about
you know intelligibility and realness
that our best
are the best way we we participate in
the way we talked about earlier
reality is through intelligibility it's
our it's our best
uh way of getting um
the platform by which we can walk a
little bit more and more closer
uh to what is perhaps real in that
absolute sense but i agree
i think it's i think it's hubristic and
i think it's just
i think it's damaging to think we have
the real
in the really real sense in some sort of
complete sense i i argue against that
consistently on the second point
i agree that if we don't get back
to helping people improve
those two things in an integrated
fashion intelligible realness
that they have that things make sense to
them and they feel that that sense
is people want both right they're
different poles in fact of meaning like
people want things to make sense but
they also want what they make sense to
be in some sense real
right so i'll do this with i'll do this
with my students i'll say
how many of you are in deeply satisfying
romantic relationships and i'll put up
they'll put up their hands
and i said keep up your hand if you
would like to know
that your partner is cheating on you
even though that would destroy the
relationship
95 of my students keep their hands up
because they don't want it if it's not
real even if it's making beautiful sense
to them
they ultimately also want it to be real
and so i think that if we do not
give if we if we do not afford people
a way of well i don't know
drinking more and more from the ongoing
fount of intelligibility
in a way that they think is realizing
them in some fashion
i think it's going to it is i wouldn't
even say it's going to it is producing
uh ill health both at the individual and
and collective level
uh and so these issues are not uh and i
don't mean i don't use this adjective
pejoratively here but these issues are
not
academic issues these are existential
issues
and so i think people ignore them at
their peril
one more time i'm not saying everybody
has to be a philosopher or a scientist
but there has to be this problem can't
be left unaddressed
okay let's go to the washing half two
minutes yeah
i'll be back in two minutes john do you
have to go as well yeah i'm going to go
as well
all right i'm back how's it going
good how is it going how is good how is
it i'm relieved
you're relieved how what the washroom
yeah yeah uh are are we getting a lot of
uh are we gonna do at some point or uh
yeah it's actually better if
you all continue talking and i'll wait
for bernardo before i say my next
comments but it's better if you
continue to talk questions there are
questions
but these questions will then
be the seed of a four-hour discussion
and you're already in one so
we may as well just continue okay well i
i like
and uh i like moving between these two
between debate and dialogues
uh thank you for we're gonna get back to
debate okay that's fine i'm happy to
just stay here too
um because these issues are issues that
really matter to me as well
but i mean
bernardo is coming at this and i mean
this is a real compliment he's coming at
this
like in really good faith um and uh
and i'm always willing i want to talk to
and i want to be open to listening to
people who are
coming at this with you know thoughtful
good faith and that's clearly the case
with him
and so yeah well so is it with you so
thank you okay well you're welcome i
just
uh i just uh this is very very enjoyable
yeah thanks it's always enjoyable when
when i speak to you or at least when i
get a chance to listen to you most of
the time i'm listening rather than
speaking to you
i enjoyed i think it was two years ago
we had a couple conversations
in person it was that long ago yeah
almost two years ago
in the summer it will be two years you
were abstaining from chocolate then
yeah i i i've been able to uh well i'm
on new medication for
my meniere's and i've been on it since
about six months now and it's been just
enormously successful
uh and so um yeah i can indulge
occasionally in a chop
in chocolate uh you're looking good man
someone said
that you're sexy but wrong
which one would you rather uh i don't
know
um i just
i don't i mean i i you know
bo both aspects of what what's been
going on with us bernardo
i've been really enjoyed it i was i was
telling
kurt you know i i you're obviously
i love to talk to people even when i
disagree with them at some points but
people that are coming at this with you
know with reflective good faith
um you know uh it's deeply appreciative
uh so i suppose maybe in the end that
i'm choosing sexy over
here i reciprocate your feeling by the
way
john i'm having a lot of fun and i i can
hardly believe it's been two hours
already
yeah okay let's get to debate now
because we were just talking about
idea hugging forget about that let's
conflict let's have some swords
where do you all disagree
the most well i'm not i'm not quite
clear on that actually
given a lot of the discussion here um i
know ontologically you disagree
whereas bernardo excuse me if i'm
paraphrasing incorrectly but you were
saying that
we can have different contents of
consciousness that are all the same much
like
there are different fields in quantum
physics that are all one underlying
field at least in a grand unified theory
and
now and what i meant is you can
produce diversity out of
unity if you take into account the
notion
of excitation and this is what physics
does all the time
so you can have a single field it's all
that exists
so you would say well then there is only
one thing how come there is this
idea that there is diversity in the
universe and physics solves this by
saying okay
that one field has many possible
different
patterns of excitation on harmonics and
those are the differences
so you account for the phenomenological
difference or diversity without
departing from ontological unity
and so it's something that physics has
regularly done more and more
maybe it's overdoing it but it it gives
us a sort of a
handle on how to deal with diversity
without
uh inflating the the reduction base
and so uh the the
analogy i take it is that
um when i was pointing to multiple
i guess they'd be analogous to particles
uh yeah
within within consciousness uh
that you are saying that they are just
modes of a field
is that is that is that a good way of
putting it on that under
under quantum field theory there is no
electron
as an entity it's just a
shorthand for a ripple on a field so say
and that field can repo in different
places in different ways
and those different patterns of rippling
would account for
the properties of the elementary
subatomic particles
so under quantum field theory there are
actually
no particles uh there are only fields
and that's the only way to reconcile uh
quantum theory which you know we know is
true at the microscopic level
to reconcile that with general
relativity which we know is true
at the macroscopic level the only way to
reconcile them
is to use this notion of fields which
began with
maxwell in the 19th century that was
maxwell's great
insight following up on faraday's notion
of
an electromagnetic field maxwell's
insight was to
treat it mathematically uh as a field
but i take it that the patterns in the
field are also real
because that's precisely what allows you
to explain
the differences yeah that would be the
postulate of course
john as far as philosophy of science is
concerned i am an anti-realist
i think theoretical entities are
useful fictions and and i don't think
they need to be anything more
than used for fiction in other words
nature behaves
as though there were quantum fields
and and that's all we need to know we do
not need to know whether the quantum
fields
are uh actually and literally real so
long as they allow us to build a model
that is predictively accurate that
predicts nature's uh
behavior so that's why i will not agree
fully uh with what you just said but
under the premises of
realist philosophers of science the
quantum field would be
real as such although it's entirely
abstract
yeah so i didn't mean to commit you to
something there i was just trying to get
the depths of the analogy
uh and so i'll take it to be an analogy
and not commit you to anything
at the level of quantum mechanics so
what i'm trying to get at is
that there is a field and the field is
real but there's also
mods and modulations in the field and
they're also real
yeah those those harmonics of the field
are taken to be real insofar as they are
the basis to explain the reality
of a measurable phenomena which are then
taken to be real too
okay so so
and and then that's one thing i i i'm
trying to
i think i'm getting from your ontology
and the other is the
uh the idea is is a kind of monism that
at base
your your ontology has to ground in one
thing
uh and because if you have more than one
thing you
then you have an unexplained
relationship between the things is that
kind of
is that correct yeah the argument
against
substance dualism is one interaction
problem if the substances are
ontologically distinct how can they
interact the other one is the causal
closure
issue we are very convinced that the
physical world is causally closed even
though
we don't really have a reason to think
that
because you know from microscopic laws
to macroscopic phenomena all kinds of
unknown things can be playing
yeah which we cannot know because there
is no control no experiment done under
controlled conditions in the world at
large
but so the causal
uh closure of the world would be another
argument and the third argument is
parsimony
right uh so why wouldn't
you why wouldn't those push you towards
something like a neoplatonic
conclusion or a spinozistic conclusion
or some versions of non-dualism which
say
well no actually mind and matter are
actually two different modes
of of some underlying thing that would
explain
ultimately the relationship uh between
them without
uh denying their their different uh
here's and i'm using
this i think correctly they're different
modalities um
uh and so and you know and so ultimately
there is like a neoplatonism there there
is the one
and the one is neither conscious nor
material it transcends both
and therefore right or spinoza's god who
is neither
right who is neither mental nor physical
et cetera so
and that and that strikes me as
following very cleanly from the those
two
things we've just talked about right you
where you've got
ammonism and you've got right and
and you've got this idea of modes um uh
of that everything that isn't the one
thing is a mode of that one thing
this is this is a a position in
philosophy called the duo aspect monism
arguably spinoza was a multi-aspect
monastery yeah he's not just do a loss
yeah yeah it's not just dual aspect
that's unfair to spinoza he really
thinks of it as it's a
as an inexhaustible thing right that you
can't actually capture it
so this this is an official position in
in a sense that it's seriously discussed
um i i don't adopt it for the following
reason
i don't think we need to postulate a
third
unknown thing which only reveals itself
through material and mental aspect i
don't think that's needed
because all we know and can know about
what we call matter
is essentially mental even our
abstractions are mental
our inferences are mental the material
quote material world we see around us
is made of qualities it's made of colors
scents flavors
mental things so to to postulate
anything
that isn't essentially mental i think is
justified
only if you cannot account for the facts
based on
nature's one given which is mentality
the primary datum of existence
is mentality if you if you cannot make
sense of things
based on that one given then i think you
are entitled to go into abstraction
territory and invent
unknown things uh in order to account
for everything
i happen to think that we can make sense
of everything without having to take
that step of abstraction well what about
a standard sort of platonic argument
that goes something like this
uh well mines seem to be spatiotemporal
things
at least if we're doing what you said
which is what uh how i experience it
uh and yet i seem to need to invoke
non-spatiotemporal things
um you know that i love certain logical
principles for example that i need to
make use of in my reasoning um and and
trying to
like does the does the law of
non-contradiction have a spatio-temporal
existence that seems wrong
that seems to to not capture uh the kind
of entity it is
or most of math muscle right and so the
idea is
well and then and then which do i use to
explain which well i actually use the
logic
and the mathematics to explain
and make my inferential conclusions
about my consciousness
and those things don't seem to be
spatial temporal and therefore
and there you go and that's what i need
i need something other than mentality
in order to get intelligibility i think
the tendency or the the notion to
to postulate non-spatial temporal things
i think it's uh when we do that we are
confusing
a mental archetype with a thing for
instance aristotelian logic
it's something that um for which
there is no objective um proof
logic is a set of axioms for instance
using the law of excluded mid
middle that's an axiom there is an
entirely coherent alternative in logic
called intuitionism
which dispenses with the law of excluded
middle and it's valid
so logic is founded on a set of axioms
that appeal directly to our intuition
in a way that seems to dispense with the
need for argument it's it's self-evident
um the whole of mathematics in a sense
is is based on these things that are
self-evident
2 plus 2 is 4 by definition because we
make it so
right and we have arguments for instance
for y multiplying a negative and a
positive number of results in a negative
number
um but these are things that are not
empirical they're mental and yet they
seem to be entirely objective
so i would say the objectivity arises
from the fact that these are
archetypal patterns of mind these are
the natural harmonics
the natural ways in which mind gets
excited
the the intrinsic natural modes of
mentation
they aren't things and yet they are
objective because of that
so we don't need to postulate something
non-mental
to account for mental objectivity all we
need to understand
is that mind itself has some
preferential modes i mean that goes back
to jung and
goes back to plato's forms
so archetypes are just regularities of
behavior they don't need to be things
that exist
in in in a place somewhere i think that
roger penrose makes this mistake
i mean if i am to be so bold as to point
out
a mistake by roger penrose but roger is
a trialist
and what he sees as the domain of
values platonic values i think we can
account for those as
merely the natural frequencies of
excitation of mind we don't need to go
beyond mind
so i mean this is what i find
challenging because
it seems like this is getting into a
kind of normalism again
which is the i and that it gets
i find it very hard to reconcile that
with scientific practice
because i if i'm going to
the relationships between
spatio-temporal things are not
themselves spatial temporal
if i want to make the kinds of
inferences i'm making for example you're
making inferences about all of reality
and i take it that all of reality is not
itself a spatial temporal thing
oh i see you're right right and so
therefore
uh you have to invoke non-spatial
temporal
uh things uh and they're normative on us
we acquiescing them
that was plato's point we would say oh
this is better than that
yes and we we can move around in our
logics but but i don't think that's
ultimately problematic
um and the point i'm trying to make is
that's
radically other than my experience of my
mind which is as a spatial temporal
limited locatable perishing yet
and you know i i talked to my my sister
and she tells me and i think she's being
directly honest that there was a time
when i did not exist
and i take that to be the case but i
don't think she's lying
and i'm not a solipsist and i don't
think you're a solipsist um
and so it seems to me that there's
aspects of reality that are unlike my
mind
and that my mind seems to be essentially
spatial temporal and these things are
not spatial temporal and yet they're
normative
on our decisions about what is real i
think your mind as an
individual person with private
conscience in their life i think that is
finite
i think our bodies our metabolism is
what
uh dissociation looks like when observed
from across a dissociative boundary and
dissociation comes from
it comes to an end but the underlying
mind which is the only thing that ever
existed i don't think that comes to an
end it's
the thing where all beginnings and ends
uh take place
um on what i mentioned about archetypes
and science
there's a paper written in 1960 by
eugene wigner
title i'll paraphrase it the amazing
effectiveness of mathematics to describe
the laws of nature or something like
this and he used the word
miracle 12 times in that paper and and
his his wonder was
why would axiomatic human thinking
the things we take to be self-evident
why would
those axioms of human mentation apply to
the behavior of the universe at large
that's a great mystery and i think
associating
the laws of nature to archetypes of the
same minds that underlies us and nature
in a way that we are
ontologically continuous with nature
would make sense of that
but i do understand the point you made
which is
if i frame everything in spatial
temporal terms
uh then i'm taking space-time as a sort
of objective
primary scaffolding of nature out there
and
do we have reasons to believe that to be
the case no we have plenty of reasons to
believe that that is precisely
not the case that's coming up from
neuroscience now it's coming up from
physics with
loop quantum gravity in which space time
is now
a derivative phenomenon of quantum
processes it's
not a pre-existing scaffolding of the
universe
so the problem is that space-time is
built into our language
our way of making arguments so i i
cannot escape that so i i
when i talk about excitations i'm
appealing to space-time because we think
in spatial temporal terms as can't put
it in triple hour two
space and times are space and time are
modes of our cognition
it if if i am to talk about something
without pre-assuming space and time i
can't even open my mouth
because language already presupposes
tenses uh
present past and future principles a
distinction between object and subject
which requires
space that was schopenhauer's principle
individualness
for two things to be different they have
to be within a certain
extended dimension um so
don't take me wrong i don't think space
time a primary is just that
if i try to be consistent with what i
actually think i can't open my mouth
so so everything i say that is framed
under the the notion of space and time
you should take it as what i believe to
be
penultimate truths they point at an
ultimate truth that i
can't capture uh can't corral into the
space-time framework of language
well i i'm happy with that i mean that's
uh i mean that that's a very
that is that is a neoplatonic conclusion
that
the the one as the ground of
intelligibility is not something that
uh that we can intelligibly grasp
because it affords all intelligible
grasping
and so it's by definition inherently a
mystery because we can't frame it
because it's behind all framing
and i think that that's going to follow
in any monism that you're going to have
something at the bottom
uh by the way i'm also honest so i don't
have a problem
with that uh i guess what i was pointing
back to was the phenomenology which is
it seems to me that um you i don't know
what to call it i think in
one of your videos you called it cosmic
consciousness i'm not i i don't want to
give you the wrong i want to talk about
the consciousness that isn't my
introspective personal consciousness
that's fine mind is a large cosmic
consciousness i find this perfectly good
descriptive terms which i i used cosmic
consciousness in like
in an academic paper on purpose
tongue-in-cheek a little bit
because i wanted to dispel this
association with new age cosmic
consciousness is perfectly descriptive
okay i won't i'm not i'm not invoking
any
new age woo-woo um i just wanted your
term for this
because there seems to be then it seems
to me a difference
a very significant difference in degree
or maybe a difference in kind
between my consciousness which seems to
be again a perishable
uh spatial temporally bound thing uh
that
is not fully present to itself um
and the the cosmic consciousness which
seems
to be very different um because i take
it that it ultimately
is identical to uh the the ground
the what i would call the one um and
which i take to not be
spatial temporal to be in no in some
sense
if it's one it has to be present to
itself throughout because if it's not
present to itself it's not one
and so there seems to be a radical
difference between my consciousness
and i assume your consciousness and the
the cosmic consciousness
and why isn't that that's really big
because you know spatial temporal and
mysterious and not and co-present to not
these are all big differences you know
and when you get enough differences in
degree don't you get a difference in
kind isn't it different
isn't that a different kind of thing i
don't know
okay but okay okay it's a common i i i
i'll
use a certain word and not individu
disrespect to you
it's just that it's a technical word i
think this is a common and ever more
popular fallacy the idea that
differences in degree can lead to a
difference in kind
i think life is a particular state of
consciousness
if you've ever had a high dose deep
psychedelic trip
you would know that that's not spatial
temporal you
you get into territories into certain
configurations or states of mind
that are not spatial temporal at all um
and you come back and you can't talk
about it because we just don't have the
words
but those are very concrete very present
states of mind i think life is a
particular state of consciousness a kind
of trance
and and we shouldn't attribute the
qualities of this particular state
to mind at large for instance i i always
warn people to not antrapomorphize mind
at large by attributing to it
our ability to to plan to act in a
premeditated way to self-reflect
i think mind at large is instinctive and
that's why the laws of nature
are so predictable and stable so i think
there's an enormous difference in
quality but not in kind i think both are
mental in the sense that both are
qualitative or experiential
well okay um i mean
these are i mean i think you get into
sorry these paradoxes if differences is
the degree don't eventually become
differences of kind uh and so i i do
think there is a need for that
but the belief of that is that you would
have to pinpoint
exactly at what point there is a sudden
translation in kind
because you see i can add more speakers
to my hi-fi but at what point does it
turn into a television you see what i
mean
well i mean category well i can add
a lot of individual units that can't do
computation together
and they together can do computation i
mean
and so uh there is there is there are
all those kinds of transitions
so well let's take that let's take that
an exam this is close to me because i'm
a computer engineer
first that was my first doctorate
everything
that that a computer does and look my
hobby is to build computers eight-bit
computers here
behind me there's a corner of society in
which i'm more or less famous for
building this this this computer from
scratch
everything a computer does can be done
with uh pipes water and pressure driven
sure
multiple realizability yeah yeah so all
those computations it's just a
difference of
two states zero or one so you can have a
valve that is shut or open pressure
driven evolves pipes and water so if you
people in strong ai now who say that a
complex enough
computer will be conscious the challenge
to them is to explain
at what point you add enough pipes
taps and water for a system that is only
pipe steps and water to become conscious
if it already doesn't start as being
conscious what is it
about extra pipe steps and water that
turns it conscious
i think what we are doing there is the
classical hand waving
we are trying to bury the problem under
a layer of obfuscating complexity
and then we hand wave our way thing and
then some something magical happens
there
and i can't explain it to you because
it's too complex
no it's still just pipes taps and water
if it didn't start as conscious it will
not become conscious
because the properties you change or add
by adding pipes taps and water
are incommensurable with the property
you want to emerge or the transitioning
kind you want to have produced
that would be my view and then if you
disagree i would challenge you to
explain to me exactly
how a sufficient high number of pipe
steps and water
can change something in kind
okay well let me try to finish the point
i was going to make
because i wanted to um because
i think you have an analogous problem
which is if cosmic mind
is not itself intelligent you now have
the problem of how does it get arranged
such that intelligence
emerges intelligent
you said it can't plan or it's act
instinctively you can have an
instinctive intelligence that is not
informed by
metacognition so
it's not capable of rationality then it
can't reflect on itself
and correct its own behavior in any
fashion that's what i think
because the laws of nature are so
predictable and because it took so many
years so many billions of three and a
half billion years of evolution
so we still have the problem of how
rationality emerges
right uh from things that are not
rational
oh that that that's not a hard problem
that's the problem of ai and ai
exists right and so what you admit
is i can take things that are
non-rational and put them together in
the right way and get rationality
yes yes yes okay so why and we
we now think that we can we got a pretty
good answer of how we can take
non-living stuff and put it together and
get living things yes
that's a more subtle problem i i would
say yes but uh i qualified yes
okay so i've got a qualified yes for
life and i've got a strong yes for
intelligence
yeah and i i didn't i can't actually in
either one of those
say to you this is the line the dividing
point this is the threshold point
biology hasn't produced it and i but we
don't
we don't thereby say oh well that means
it's not real it doesn't emerge
we say no no right it's it's precisely a
continuous change
not a bifurcation change um
and so again what's the difference
between consciousness
and you know it
i'm putting us we're pretty we're
talking about the emergence problem
if we are willing to countenance for for
life and we at one time we didn't
we thought no there's no way you know
and land vettel
and all that stuff and then for the
longest time no way no machine could
possibly be intelligent and now that's
becoming
less and less a plausible place to stand
what's the difference
then our concept of intelligence is
something that
human beings came up with there is
information processing
in nature we apply the label
intelligence not based on neutral
objective reasons
but based on what we feel is similar
enough to us
to be considered intelligent arguably a
paramecium is intelligent in the sense
that it
goes after the food it needs to and runs
away from
from from threats so
there is no such a thing as a defining
boundary
in which there is a difference in kind
all you have is information processing
we already start with it simple
information processing like a transition
between two in two states
it's all all over in nature you flip
your switch it's a transition between
one state to the other
and then we get more complex
interrelated
transitions of states there is no
fundamental
crossing of a boundary it's just where
are we comfortable to put the labor
intelligence in ai
we devised an arbitrary test to justify
that we call it the turing test
yeah and the turing test is problematic
but go ahead go ahead so there is no
fundamental transition it's just a
spectrum it's a continuum i would say
when searle in 1980 wrote
his paper on the chinese room experiment
he was appealing to conscious
understanding
his argument had nothing to do with
intelligence the mit guys were right
in their in their rebuttal to searle
because for them intelligence is just
more complex information processing so
the room
is intelligent if the manual the the
clerk is using
contains enough complex instructions for
that information processing to be
considered intelligent the intuition
sero was appealing to was
understanding not intelligence and what
is that intuition that
that intuition is the conscious
experience that goes
coupled with certain types of
information processing
that conscious experience we call
understanding and then the clerk inside
the room which is only
the only conscious entity there does not
have understanding
because he's not absorbing all the
information processing into his mind a
lot of it is in the manual
um so that's for intelligence as for
life i am sympathetic to you there but i
feel obliged to remind you that we have
not achieved a biogenesis we have
arguably achieved intelligence
there are server farms today
or you know computer farms using a lot
of
graphical accelerators running neural
networks which i would be
personally comfortable comfortable to
say this is intelligent
uh my intuition would acquiesce to that
immediately
so we have achieved that we've created
that but we have not created the life
from non-life what craig venter has
achieved was to
artificially create a dna molecule and
insert it
into a molecule that was already living
and then zap it with electricity and the
molecule changed the way it makes
proteins
but we have not achieved the biogenesis
so i think the jury is still
out but even if we one day achieve a
biogenesis and i personally think we
will
i think what that will mean is that
we've found an artificial way to induce
dissociation in the universal mind
because life metabolism is what
dissociative processes look like
okay so it seems to me like that
uh i don't want to get into the uh
exegetical disagreement about
how to interpret cyril in the chinese
room because i think there's independent
arguments
i think he ultimately said the art the
argument has to do with multiple
realizability
not with understanding i mean that's
what came out that was my interpretation
i'm i was not i didn't mean to attribute
to that to searle himself
okay okay so fair enough fair enough uh
but but
i i don't think we have to resolve the
interpretation of cyril to
continue our discussion is what i'm
saying um
so so
it sounds like that for you
the the the emergence of things like
life and intelligence
are not problematic but there's
something different for consciousness
and the problem i have with that is
we also have deep intuitions about the
deep relationship
and interdefining of intelligence and
consciousness most of our attributions
of consciousness
other than yours bernard i don't wanna i
don't wanna miss a tribute to you
they generally track with attributions
of intelligence
um and there are the measures of
intelligence measures of like working
memory
uh correlate also with you know models
of consciousness
uh the global workspace uh things like
that
uh consciousness seems to exist um
for those problems so you can compare
behavior
that which requires our consciousness
for behavior that doesn't
and consciousness seems to be uh those
situations that require
are our most sophisticated intelligence
situations that are complex
novel relatively unpredictable we can't
do those unconsciously
or semi-consciously we have to do them
full consciously so there seems to be
what i'm saying is
this it's very tight interweaving
between
intelligence and consciousness i
recognize what you're saying
the way i would uh try to make sense of
this
well i would say that we are conflating
phenomenal consciousness with meta
consciousness when we make this argument
meta consciousness entails phenomenal
consciousness and
access consciousness using the
definitions from block
block block 1995 yeah yeah
almost all research on consciousness
is actually exploring meta consciousness
in so far as it depends on the subject's
ability to report on what they are
experiencing
so for instance blind site studies we
say
unconscious sight well we say that
because the subject says i am not seeing
but the subject is behaving as if he or
she were
saying so i would say what what what has
gone
broken there is the feedback loop that
is required for
reportability um giulio tanoni's
information integration theory that that
phi magic find number and then if you
cross the
number you're conscious well that's
empirically calibrated based on
subjective reports
so phi captures the moment you cross the
threshold of
metacognition not the threshold of
experienced pure and simple
it's very hard to study experience
pure and simple in an objective setting
because you can only study that through
introspection it's only when you
suddenly become
meta conscious of something you were
already conscious of
all along that you realize oh darn
i i've noticed all along i knew this i
just didn't know
that i knew so this is the only way for
you to realize that there was an
experience the only thing that was
missing
was the metacognitive loop and and i
think topographically
it's really a loopy because um research
on the neurocorrelates of consciousness
always points out that you have to have
a cycle loop
closed um phi depends on that structure
of loops being closed that's what's
called information integration
previous research prior to tanoni points
out that you need this
feedback and feed forward ping-ponging
of information between two brain areas
for instance the the visual cortex and
the limbic system
if you cut that then you get for
instance blindside
and then we say oh the person is not
conscious of sight no the person is not
reporting the experience of seeing
but the person is behaving entirely
consistently
with the awareness of seeing the
phenomenal
conscious uh of vision so i
look this this is an area where so many
misunderstandings have happened
throughout the history of psychology and
neuroscience
if you read jung let's let's go back to
the early 20th century
if you read jung and you distill how he
defines consciousness
you will see that what he's talking
about is matter consciousness
he talks about consciousness
consciousness requiring an associative
web if you don't have this web of
associations
it's not conscious he talks about
consciousness
uh having to be coupled to a and if you
read what he means by the will what he
means is deliberation
reflection he's talking about reflection
self-reflection
he talks about children slowly becoming
conscious in the first years of their
lives
does he mean by that that his his five
children
did not experience anything until they
were seven of course he didn't mean that
um there are neuroscientists today who
define consciousness
as meta consciousness and i think it's
fine to use the word that way
the moment where it goes wrong is when
we
think we've solved the problem because
we are using the word consciousness when
in fact
we are we mean matter consciousness and
we are not solving the problem of
consciousness at all
that's my grievance about what happens
today so is
meta consciousness though the only way
we have access
experiential access to our consciousness
to consciousness i don't i mean i don't
have access to your consciousness
um so
i think the best paper on this is from
2002
i forgot the name of the author um
i can send it to you offline afterwards
sure
sure
the author explains that we have
experiences
and meta conscious consciousness is what
happens
when we re represent those experiences
so suppose we are talking about
perception then we have a direct
perceptual experience that's
representational by definition it's
perception
but at some point we re-represent
our own inner representations in order
to investigate
the contents of our own awareness that's
the point where meta consciousness
arises it's this step of
re-representation and
that's that's not built into experience
so if you'd say
do we need that to access our
experiences
i would say no because experiences are
accessible as experiences
but we need that to explicitly access
our experiences
if i go back to young everything jung
has said it all in old-fashioned
language but everything is in young
jung said in answer to job
god is omniscient but he doesn't know
how to consult
his omniscient the devil is much more
clever
in knowing how to consult uh omniscience
what is he talking about he's talking
about meta consciousness
so i think we have experiential access
to everything
in our own minds but we cannot
deliberately
access all of it because not all of it
can be placed under the microscope of
reflection
at our own will we don't have that much
control over our
over the entirety of the psyche
so um
let me make sure i understand you so
what you're saying is we do have access
to experience that's non-reflective
access
some kind of experiential access to that
yeah
sorry that sounds sorry that's
uncircular you're saying you don't want
to say
like you don't want to get into an
infinite request that i have qualia
qualia is what it is to experience
because then i'd have to have qualia for
my qualia and i'd have to have
but we cannot explicitly re-represent
everything that is experienced in our
own minds for instance i'd maintain
that five minutes ago you were
experiencing your breathing
but you were not re-representing the
experience of your breathing
therefore you were not reporting to
yourself i am breathing but i wasn't
experiencing my belief that africa was a
continent which i'm experiencing right
now
yeah what's that so what
what you're trying to say that that
belief well i take it yeah
i mean i i i i have the belief
uh but i'm not experiencing it until i
just did now africa is a continent but i
have the belief
and i know that i have the belief
because if you ask me i'll say yes
and uh when i look on a map i'll say
there's one of the continents but i'm
not doing that constantly
so that's not the evidence that's the
evidence that i have the belief it's not
the belief so i'm
not the i i reject behaviorism of belief
right the beliefs are something other
of the the behavior and you're nodding
so i think you agree with that
and yet um i wasn't experiencing that uh
and in fact most of what i believe i'm
not experiencing
right now right now yeah yeah i
understand the heart of your argument
and you and you're poking in the right
place because you already understood
that a direct implication of what i'm
saying is that everything has to be
experiential
there is no other place for psychic
content to
lay dormant waiting to be experienced
because by definition analytic idealism
says everything is experiential
so we have to have a mental mechanism
that is able to compartmentalize
experience such that you are not able to
access
all of those experiences and now of
course
what we mean by you is is part of of the
answer
but i would postulate two things as
mechanisms for that
one is what we've been talking about um
metacognition metacognition
not only amplifies the contents that are
re-represented because you can pile up
re-pile up
re-representation on top of
re-representation you can know that you
know that you know that you're
experiencing and so on and it obfuscates
everything else another mechanism i
would
put forward to use dissociation i mean
and i think there is now plenty of
empirical evidence that the association
is
strong enough to do exactly what i
needed to do which is to
compartmentalize
experience completely including your
experience of the knowledge of africa
because you know in 2015 people in
germany two researchers in germany
um they they they were dealing with a
woman who claimed to have
multiple dissociated altars amongst
which two claimed to be
blind although there was nothing wrong
physically with the woman's abilities
ability to see and the host personality
could see perfectly well
so they had this brilliant idea of
hooking her up to an eeg cap
uh and measuring her visual cortex
activity
while a sighted altar was in control
and then there was normal visual cortex
activity and when the blind alter
would uh take executive control visual
cortex reactivity would disappear
even though the woman's eyes were wide
open and things were happening in front
of her
now dissociation is powerful enough to
be literally blinding
so i would think of a hierarchy of
dissociative processes we know many
types of dissociative processes
not only forgetting things but losing
the sense of ownership to your own
memories even though you still remember
the memories but they feel like they are
alien memories somebody else's memories
all kinds of dissociation all different
degrees of dissociation
and multiple levels of re-representation
hierarchical re-representation
i would put forward to you that these
two things these two complex processes
that we know happen the existing nature
there is no
empirical doubt about it they are
sufficient
to compartmentalize mind in such a way
that you
think a lot of things that are happening
in
the mind of nature are not actually
happening because they're not accessible
to you you may be dissociated from them
you may not be re-representing them you
may be obfuscating them
all kinds of hierarchical levels of of
compartmentalizing processes may be
taking place and i submit to you that
although this sounds complex
it's a lot more plausible and less
complex than the alternatives
like the combination problem in
bottom-up pan psychism or
constitutive pensionism or the heart
problem of consciousness for which we
don't even have in-principle answers
so i guess
you're willing to countenance the
existence of processes that are outside
consciousness modifying it because
that's what dissociation is
i mean if it's blind your consciousness
well whose consciousness
is it residing is it residing in cosmic
mind consciousness
i think there is only one consciousness
and what we consider to be
us is a dissociative complex of that one
consciousness
so is the one but where is the
dissociation where does it exist
in in the one consciousness who yeah but
some consciousness must be aware of it
so is the cosmic consciousness aware of
the dissociation
that's what consciousness it means
the dissociation from both sides from
the inner side which is us we are part
of nature we are not a separate entity
and it experiences the dissociation from
the other side the side of the inanimate
universe and and those experiences
are presented to us in the form that we
call
the inanimate universe which is a
representation of what is essentially
natural instinctive mental processes
unfolding beyond the boundary of our own
dissociation so
schopenhauer it's it's the will inside
and it's the wheel outside
[Laughter]
so why does this dissociation occur
it's a question that that um i get all
the time
um i i will answer but i i
first invite you to ask yourself why
there needs to be
a why um is anything else in nature well
no no wait wait there does because
your whole i mean the whole defense
depends
on the dissociations and the differences
between metacognition
and dissociated cognition that is the
main thing you use
to explain the extr the external world
so if that if if i don't have any
principles by which this operates
then it's not clear to me that i've
gained anything
uh by it's just saying oh there's well
there's an external world
right and i don't quite know how that
works
anymore then you can explain to me how
the dissociation and the metacognitive
leveling works
yeah okay i understand what you mean now
you didn't you were not asking for a
reason you were asking for
a process a mechanism i understand it
now
we will answer that question once we
figure out how
abiogenesis ever happened how life arose
from non-life
because i would submit to you that from
the point of view of representation
the kantian phenomena the
schopenhauerian representation
what that process looked like was the
emergence of life
because for me life is the extrinsic
appearance of dissociation
so the answer to your question is
exactly the same as the answer to the
question how did life arose from
non-life
it's just that you're looking at the
same process from two perspectives a
first person perspective
in an outside third person perspective
the perspective of representation
but it's one in the same process and
therefore it follows one in the same
mechanism
if there is a need to have a
why beyond the mechanism like why did
the universe do this
i don't think there is a need for that
but if there were
yeah i wasn't asking for a motive you
know okay okay
i was so i i mean i take it that that
you're saying that there are processes
that are self-organizing
in some fashion uh because we
right i i you even use that metaphor in
a couple of your videos you talk about
eddies within the river yeah yeah
and life is a lot sorry no no i'm not
making accusations i'm just trying to
making sure that i'm
i'm getting you correctly and whatever
life is it's it's a very complex
self-organizing thing
i mean and i actually think that varela
is right it's an autopoetic thing and
not just a self-organizing thing
and that's that's what allows me to say
that the paramecium is to some degree
and
intelligent and the tornado is not
because the tornado does not do anything
it does not seek out the conditions that
produce protect or promote its existence
and the paramecium does um and so
i'm with you all the way what i'm
putting forward
does not require any change in our
scientific understanding of
how life works and how it arose it just
provides a a another perspective to the
same process
i'm saying that there is actually an
inner perspective
that the representation is not the whole
story
it's a valid story it it is an accurate
representation of the process so
knowledge gained
by looking at the process as it unfolds
in the physical world this valid
knowledge
all i'm saying is that the thing in
itself which lies behind how it's
represented
by our perception cognitive apparatus
that thing in itself is mental
and it is of a dissociative character
but it's not changing any science
no no but yeah i i get that i i would
not uh
i hope i wasn't implying that because i
didn't i didn't see you saying that
um but that's that's sort of the what
the problem i'm coming up with
it looks like the science stays the same
um
and we we do okay um and then and then
you invoke the principle of parsimony
i'll invoke a principle which is
don't invoke in your explanation an
entity more controversial than the
entity
in the thing you're trying to explain
and you're ultimately invoking what
looks to me like god
um which i would need independent
evidence for this con i mean
other than right in in a circular
fashion i would need an
i would need independent evidence for
cosmic mind
right in in order to
make this argument run and that's been a
very problematic thing to do
for a very very long time the thing is
you're appealing to controversial
something controversial which is an
entirely culture laden
thing is it controversial or not it's
entirely subjective
i didn't talk about god anywhere i even
volunteered to you that i think this
universal mind is instinctive
and naturalistic it's not premeditated
it's not anthropomorphic
so how that you attribute
the quality of being controversial to it
i would
dare to submit to you that it's an
entirely subjective value judgment
no okay what i meant was typical so
other than that let's try to make it a
little bit more formal uh that i don't
invoke
something that requires argumentation uh
right as much as the argument i'm giving
um
i'll submit to you that mine is the
simplest in terms of argumentation it
requires no miracle
it requires no strong emergency it
requires no magical combination of
fundamentally separate subjective points
of view and there is a host of empirical
substantiation for it
beat that um
well i mean i i still think you have the
equivalent of what the pan psychist has
you have an
explanation this needs to be forthcoming
of how i get
living minded rational uh
entities like me out of a mind that is
not
uh biologically alive that is not
capable of rational etc etc etc it seems
to me that i don't know what i've gained
by replacing the external world
from which i have to explain
intelligence and consciousness and
rationality
from saying well there's this other mind
out there
that is but it's it's not capable
it doesn't have rationality it doesn't
have personality it doesn't have
all of the features of god for example
and it's and
and right and and and then there's some
self-organizing process that
emerges well that sounds to me like well
there's matter
it doesn't have all these properties
there's some self-organizing process
and it and mind and life emerge what's
the difference between the two moves
if you think it's implausibly complex to
say
that complex minds like ours have
evolved from a very
simple phenomenal substrate imagine how
implausible it is to say that complex
minds like ours
emerged out of no mind which one is
better
there they seem to me to be not
different that's my point
they seem to logically one requires a
huge ontological jump from no mind to
mind
the other one only requires degrees the
thing is
you're very focused on this notion that
degree can lead to a
difference in kind which i think is a
fallacy
but but you're invoking it you're
invoking it because you're saying
that the cosmic mind is ultimately
different in kind
from my mind that's why my trip that's
why me calling it something like god
is fundamentally a mistake because it
doesn't have
some of the fundamental features of my
personhood which is what
the traditional definition of god is i'm
not saying it's different in kind
because i'm saying it's also mental
in the sense that its processes are of
an experiential or qualitative nature
but the complexity of those processes
the inner interactions the changes of
state the structure and dynamics of
those processes
can vary over large degrees and the
substrate is still the same
field of subjectivity the same field of
phenomenality
so there is no ontologically there is no
transition in kind
it's a transition of sophistication
the complexity of the processes that
unfold there if
you will um the the
the underlying mind at large you can
look at it as a lake
with simple straight ripples and
and in our minds with all kinds of you
know higher level mental functions
feedback mechanisms
intelligence rationality self-reflection
self-awareness re-representation and all
that stuff
as a very stormy
[Laughter]
water in a cup but very stormy water in
a cup with all kinds of patterns of
movement
that are much more complex waves that
fold in
upon themselves and form reflective
surfaces
uh all kinds of uh um access
uh patterns uh going on but it's water
but you're invoking new kinds all kinds
of patterns
all kinds of things patterns of
excitation
that are real yes but not a different
kind of the medium that is excited
so look you can have so so so there's
ultimately
physics which isn't just matter it's
time and space
and quantum crap and relativistic crap
and some of it gets very complex
and that's me and some of it doesn't get
very complex and that's a rock
i mean
and i take it that there's a difference
in kind between me and rocks and i think
you do too because you treat persons
with morality
in a way you don't treat rocks with
morality so there's a difference in kind
there that comes out in your in your
behavior in a very predictable manner
i think there's a difference in
complexity which leads to different
properties
and you can pass judgments based on the
properties that are available but i
don't think there is
a difference in kind as far as the
ontological substrate is concerned it's
still mental it's still subjectivity
you can have very simple ripples and
very complex ripples but it's still
just ripples in water it's still just
water
or you can have a silicon i want to
point out to you the irony that you're
using a physical analogy
uh to describe this thereby pointing to
the fact that physical things can
actually do the kind of stuff you're
pointing to
i'm not denying that which we call the
physical i'm denying the theoretical
inference that that which we call the
physical has a root in something
non-mental
but i'm not denying the experience of
the world that we call physical
right um
john i feel like you're holding back
what are your true thoughts uh
no i'm not holding back in the sense
that there's stuff i want to say that
i'm not saying
i'm i i there's uh i i think there's uh
and i don't mean this pejoratively to
either bernardo or myself
i think there's an intuitive vision here
that we're not necessarily sharing
um um what do you mean by that
uh i think the the the the
intuitions about i mean it seems to me
like
bernardo is saying that you know the
world exists independently of my mind
um but it doesn't exist independently of
some mind
that i'm not directly aware of uh and
that's
that strikes me as uh problematic
because i would need evidence for that
mind independent of me
in order to make the argument run i got
it so
the analogy i like to use for this is
the following
unless we are solipsists unless we think
that the only mind going on is our own
meant
our own mind the ones we have direct
access to so
i i would consider that something
something that we don't need to debate
we can reject that i even wrote about an
argument to reject that but
i know you i know you reject it as
russell said even those who purport to
believe in solipsism
actually don't act as if they believe
it's a performative contradiction yes
totally
okay so unless you wear that you have to
infer something outside of that which
you have direct access to
you have to make an inference beyond
your own mind unless you're a solipsist
so the difference is what is that
inference how complex how
how parsimonious and how explanatory
powerful is that inference
but everybody has to make that inference
so the analogy i use is the following
my mind is the earth i can see until the
horizon
beyond the horizon i cannot see directly
but i
need to infer that the earth that there
is something be
beyond the horizon to make sense of
empirical experience otherwise i do not
have
a satisfactory explanatory model for how
you and me seem to be sharing the same
world and all that uh granting that you
also
are conscious i reject solipsism too i
rejected all those scissors too
so i my my influence is the following
up to the horizon it's my mind it's
mental
beyond the horizon it's just more mind
it's just that i cannot see it
the physicalist will say up to the
horizon it's my mind it's mental
beyond the horizon it's a totally
different kind of stuff
that is exhaustively definable in terms
of pure quantities
and out of which we do not have a way
even in principle to derive
qualities take your picture okay
oh well i i mean that's a little bit of
a prejudicial
description because it sounds like
there's no problems in your
in your position also but let's let's
let's
let's do that then so we agree that
there isn't solipsism so we agree
that there's things that exist outside
of my consciousness
and that taking care of the problem that
i didn't exist at one point and i won't
exist at another point
and so the issue then i i guess becomes
i should there and the reason why people
believe in the external world
typically is they think of things going
on outside of any human consciousness
um you know that they're before you know
before they were sentient beings
the earth was forming the sun was
forming you know you know
things like that evolution was
eventually going on uh you know
et cetera et cetera and
what they the physical still doesn't say
is well when i
look at reality when i first come upon
it where there has not been any human
beings i don't see any evidence
uh for intelligence and i don't see any
evidence
for directed behavior i don't see any
evidence for what
i i typically need in order to attribute
mind to something
so i don't attribute mine to my
refrigerator normally because it doesn't
have
blah blah blah blah it doesn't do all
these things and that's why
you know and that's how i make
distinctions between my mind and the
dog's mind etc
in terms of the behavioral consequences
and the physicalist says
well it looks like most of the universe
is behaving as if there is no mind
and what i would need for the cosmic
mind is evidence outside of human
consciousness
of things that are mental like in
behavior and that's exactly not what the
universe seems to operate like
it seems to operate non-teleologically
not intelligently
it seems to happen like really
haphazardly it doesn't have to seem to
have even the basis
of moral concerns or emotional
attachment to anything
why would i attribute mine to that okay
i don't think you're right when you say
there is no evidence for that
but suppose you were right that there is
no evidence for us to attribute mind to
the world
i would still say that is by far
still the least problematic option given
what options are on the table how do you
produce
qualities out of purely quantitative
properties
or how do you merge uh fundamentally
different
fields of experience it's different it's
a different matter
this is coming down to intellectual
taste i mean
really i mean because what you're asking
me to say that we
that you know we have some our
experience has some special role
like you know this is one of the
criticisms made by speculative realists
you know correlationalism that we're
we're binding all of ontology
uh uh uh to our particular uh
ontology and that that seems like a a
really
uh a really unjustifiable i i want to be
able to talk about things having
relations
among themselves without me being around
i agree with that
right i will answer that i will answer
that let me just
very briefly insist on the point i made
before in the technical literature
there are papers papers arguing that the
problems faced by
physicalism and psychism leads to
incoherence
and these are technical arguments made
by different people
i i've read though i've read i've read a
lot of these arguments too right okay
and there are also people that counter
those arguments i mean
it's not it's not fair for you to
present it as a resolve debate or
consensus
i don't think that's that's fair there
has been no
technical argument saying that analytic
idealism is incoherent in principle
these arguments have been made for the
other two options
but there is no in principle incoherence
argument
for instance for uh constitutive
pennsylvanism the incoherent
incoherence argument takes this the
following form
if fundamentally separate fields of
subjectivity
experiencing different qualities were to
merge
he would lose the original fields of
experience like if if the compound
subject is seeing purple
and the sub-subjects were seeing red and
blue
then they would subsume themselves into
the higher level subject which
contradicts what the penn psychism is
trying to do
which is to follow the rules of uh
chemical combinations in philip
physicalism
uh the the molecules that compose
tissues
don't disappear so you have an argument
like that
there isn't a technical argument
claiming incoherence for analytical
idealism
there may be i find it very hard but
there may be but still let me grant you
that um that i cannot use this line of
arguments and let's look at what you
said you said
um for something to be minded you you
need to care about
relationships you need to be emotionally
bound to something
solving problems even yeah it does a
mosquito have those properties
there's a crocodile have all these
properties you're alluding to
can you envision that water flea
is a purely instinctive reactive
conscious being that does not have any
of these
experiential qualities that we have
a paramecium i think paramecium
has um the
sort of basic abilities of making sense
aspectualizing its environment so it's
it relates to some things as food and
some things as poison
and i think that as spectralization is
continuous with how you're aspect
realizing
right now you're seeing me as a man
you're seeing me as
etc etc so there's deep continuity
between their capacity for aspect
realization
and mine but that doesn't mean that they
could aspectualize
right everything that i can because
i don't have to attribute the same
intelligence to them as i attribute to
me that's exactly my point
but can you attribute a lot simpler
conscious in your life to them than you
have
like you would have none of the emotions
you have it wouldn't be anxious
it wouldn't fall in love i think the
paramecium
in some sense has to care about some
information
rather than the other it wouldn't be my
full-blown subjective experience of love
but um i you know there's many
subjective
emotions i have like pride that i don't
think a dog has but i think a dog is
nevertheless conscious
so i i think a paramecium i mean that's
one of the big differences
between us and between standard existing
computers is we have to care about the
information we're processing
um and we which means we devote
attention and arousal
we dispose metabolic energy towards it i
think the paramecium
is doing all of these things okay so i
i'm with you that there is a continuum
i'm just trying to establish that in
that continuum there is a point of
much lower much higher simplicity than
than where we are
that's the only thing i want to
establish that that can be conscious in
their life
with a lot more simplicity than the one
we experience
as human beings and we are both in a
continuum okay
now the paramecium has what philosophers
call
intentionality because there is
something outside the paramecium that
isn't the paramecium
now for the cosmic mind there is nothing
outside of it by definition so it cannot
have intentionality
so all its conscious states have to be
endogenous
and there can there can't be this
actualization that you're talking about
because there isn't
an outside environment so my what i
propose is
it's very in terms of emotions and
qualities it's much simpler in their
life
and it does not have intentionality it's
a it's purely endogenous it's of a
different kind
now is there evidence that that might be
going on
even if there weren't i would say i
still have the best theory on the table
because the problems of the others are
insurmountable but recent research is
showing two things and this
is fresh out of the oven one of them not
the first i would talk about
there is a lot of study now showing that
in terms of network topology and i'm not
talking about pretty images pretty
photographs i'm talking about
network topology which is quantified and
mathematized
there are surprising similarities
between the network topology
of the universe at its largest scales
you know galaxy clusters and all that
um and neuronal networks in mammals
that argument's been in existence for
quite a while design in nature i forget
the author of the book
he points out those that uh formal
similarity but it's also similarity with
you know how the how things branch in
your in your lungs
how river deltas branch out things like
that
recent research uh the the most recent
one is done by an italian neuroscientist
and an italian physician
um sorry you're a physicist you have the
advantage on me then i guess
go ahead well bernardo is that not a
moot point because if we had more
cosmic data and we find out that the
universe looks completely different from
another
point of view you still wouldn't say
that your theory is invalidated so in
some sense it's neither
a pro nor con this is more than just
what it looks like that's what i'm
trying to highlight
quantitative studies have been done at
the university of california at irvine
i think in 2014 and there is this more
uh
recent research done by this franco
varza
and alberto feletti these two guys
oh i'm amazed i could retrieve that
normally i'm not that good mind at large
has been kind to you
this is a quantitative network structure
and network topology analysis
and it shows the similarity is really
between
neural networks and the universe and it
doesn't involve
the fractal patterns of arteries in our
lungs or the fractal patterns of river
deltas it goes
it's much more specific than that now
there is a paper fresh
out of the oven published by a physicist
called stefon
forgot forgot to forgot his uh his other
name fresh
are these papers proposing that there's
information processing going on in this
structure
i mean that's going to violate all kinds
of relativistic limitations
et cetera no no okay so before i talk
about stefan's paper first
this because it's a good point of course
there is information processing what you
don't have is closed
loops of information because the age of
the universe is not
not long enough for information to to
go across galaxy galaxy clusters and and
close a loop
uh there hasn't been enough time for
that to happen
so what you cannot have is tononi's
information integration phi topologies
there hasn't been time for that
which only means that the universe is
then not self-reflective but it can
still be phenomenally
conscious or it can be phenomenal
conscious consciousness
because the the letter does not require
this closed loops of information
integration
for which you're right there has not
been time but information
processing in a feed forward manner of
course that's happening all the time and
it's
the universe is an information
processing engine actually there is a
whole field of physics called digital
physics
which is based entirely on on on this
postulate
but the the paper of stefon and it's
amazing um
it's beginning of research there's a
long way to go but what he's showing is
that the laws of physics may
correspond in terms of model models
may correspond to the weights of neurons
in the neural network
that the universe may be learning its
laws of physics
so i john if you say this is all
circumstantial i will be the first to
jump and agree with you but
you put me on the spot of of producing
this kind of
this kind of argument sure sure is there
any evidence and then you say well
yeah there is there actually is and it's
evidence that we are
so confused about that we cannot make
sense of it we do not know
why uh galaxy clusters look more
like a a neuron then they look like the
interior of a galaxy
why should that be the case there is
nothing now under
in our understanding of nature that
would suggest why this relationship is
there at all
that it is there and that its
information processing can actually be
modeled as the weights of a artificial
neural network in the process of
learning
but only a feedback yeah but only a
feedforward artificial network
which is exactly the point you just made
which means it can't have a lot of the
properties
that we find in any new networks that do
feedback loops on themselves
it isn't even capable of doing hidden
deep learning or anything like that
because you have right and so i mean so
this is going to be a pretty
sorry i don't mean to be insulting to
your view i'm not okay that's a pretty
stupid
uh consciousness um and it has no
intentionality
i mean and so you're talking about a
mind without in without intent what you
said
without intentionality and without even
rudimentary intelligence i mean well
again
be careful be careful there are methods
of neural network
uh learning which are only feed forward
particularly
unsupervised learning techniques that do
not require this deep feedback
mechanism so you can still have some
intelligence but remember
i started today by saying i am a
naturalist i'm just being consistent
with it
um well yeah and i want to i won't get
into the technicalities because then you
have
learning speed problems and you have
self-correction problems and debugging
problems
which is why you know we plausibly have
meta
consciousness and meta intelligence
right we can use our intelligence to
improve our intelligence
uh we learn literacy for example that
improves our capacity for problem
solving um
like yeah i mean i i guess what comes
down to it is
uh i'm not quite sure what the
difference is now
because i got something out there uh
that's
no intentionality which is unlike what i
experienced
i mean let me be fair to you i do
experience states in deep meditation
that uh that are states without
intentionality and for which you could
possibly say i'm not exercising
any significant degree of intelligence
and those are the pure consciousness
events
and they're reliable i've i've achieved
that that sounds like an achievement so
i've been in those states multiple times
i know there's lots of research foreman
has done it
and there's lots of things on that um
is that the kind of thing what people
i mean i know it's not exactly the same
but i'm trying to get something from
within what i normally point to with
consciousness is that the kind of
consciousness you see for
mind at large the kind of consciousness
without intentionality and intelligence
i have in pure consciousness event
in which i'm not even conscious of my
consciousness i'm just conscious
is it something like that yes just just
a quick
uh a clarification when i use the the
term intentionality i mean it in a
technical sense
intentionally i i do too i mean
that is lost in the pc uh pce that's one
that's
by definition definition there cannot be
intentionality because
there is no aboutness there is only the
thing by definition there's no outside
intentionality arises when you but we
achieve intentionality
yeah because there is an outside world
an outside world is created once you
have a boundary i would say that
boundary is the dissociative boundary
it's the dissociation that creates the
distinction between the inside and the
outside
and now you can have intentionality or
aboutness because there is something
outside that you don't identify yourself
with
so intentionality emerges out of
non-intentional
states through dissociation but you know
that the problem of intentionality
is regarded as deeply a problem
for physicalism as the problem of
consciousness how do you get something
like intentionality
out of the physical universe that is not
intentional right
intentional content no no
the existence of the the the existence
of intentionality
i mean so the big problems are
consciousness
intentionality right how do you get i
mean that's what i think is actually
going on by the way and i think in in
searle's chinese room argument sarah
often
describes it that way is how do i get
intentionality how do i get the things
inside the room
to be about things outside the room and
he attributes that to consciousness but
obviously that's not what you're
claiming because the universal
consciousness
sorry keep changing the names on you
that's unfair it's okay
the mind at large um doesn't have
intentionality
so it's no different than the chinese
room right because it doesn't have
intentionality
no because remember i mentioned to you
that my interpretation of
uh soros thought experiment was that
what's missing is consciousness
and here what the consciousness supplies
is intentionality
that's why cyril claims again and again
it's an argument about meaning
all the syntax is there but as he says
there's no semantics there yes it's the
intentionality
right yeah but notice now that i am
already starting with phenomenal
consciousness
so that problem of intentionality you
don't have
because how does consciousness produce
intentionality don't you have that
problem
because consciousness at large doesn't
have intentionality
but once there is a dissociative
boundary then there is an outside
state of the world and there is an
inside state of the altar
through evolution you will start trying
to represent
outside states into inner states because
that's how you survive
now that representation will never be
mirrored because otherwise you would
dissolve into an internet tropic soup
we've known that since
10 years no no no no i think i think i'm
not presented
how would i give a machine the capacity
for intentionality
the moment but now now you're
you're not thinking within the framework
of what i'm putting forward
if you're assuming the machine is not
consciousness no no but you've already
admitted that consciousness
that base consciousness doesn't have
intentionality yeah so
you don't get to have intentionality
coming along for the ride
correct consciousness that's unfair yeah
do the original consciousness
that's what i try to explain so you
start with consciousness
so now what you have to explain is
having started with phenomenal
consciousness
how does intentionality arise how does
it arise
because it's better to survive if you
can represent the external environment
into inner states
the organism will do that and these
inner states would then be
phenomenal states what else can they be
i'm saying that everything is in
consciousness
then they that's how intentionality
arises no no that's a teleological
explanation
that's telling me that no no it's not
telling me how
it arises ontologically it's telling me
how it arises teleologically it's like
well how does the eye work well there
was evolution and natural selection
selected for things that had vision
and that's how vision arose okay no no
that's not that's not what i'm asking
for
the mecca what you're asking for is how
did sensory organs
evolve you were asking for a mechanism
for that
and i would say the answer is the same
no no i'm not as
because the answer for how my eye
evolved is the same answer for how my
foot evolved
natural selection variation but that
doesn't mean that my foot functions
according to the same principles
that my eye does i want to know the
different things
i don't want to know the history i want
to know the structural functional
organization
that makes it causally possible that's
what i was trying to say
you will represent external states into
inner states
representation invokes intentionality
you're invoking the very thing you're
trying to explain
because what's the difference between a
representation and a non-representation
is that a representation possesses
intentionality then
then the the question you're asking is
how did the first sensory organ arose
because that's what does the
representation i want to
that's what does the representation that
doesn't tell me
how representation works you're pointing
me through the thing
what i'm trying to say is the answer to
your question is the same
answer that the physicalist would give
you because
it's the same process it's how did
sensorium arise
how did it happen well we we have
evolutionary biologists studying that
how would the inner states of an
organism represent the outer states of
the world around it so i don't need
a consciousness explanation therefore to
explain how intentionality
emerges out of consciousness i can give
a completely physical this mechanism
because that's what evolution is no it's
completely you can give
a purely physical explanation if you
already started with consciousness
because that's what solves the problem
cyril was
was referring to i i don't see that
because you said
the base consciousness doesn't have
intentionality so you don't get so i
need a mechanism of how something
without intentionality
gets intentionality and then you offer
me evolution which is a completely
physicalist explanation
which means i don't need physical i
don't need
consciousness to explain how i get
intentionality out of consciousness let
me try it another way try it another way
so let's forget consciousness let's talk
purely in physical terms
is it okay that we say uh
physical organisms very simple life
three and a half billion years ago
uh evolved so to represent physical
states of the world outside into
internal states
i think that's a very hard problem i
like knowing how that works
but you accept it happened yes okay
now if we accept that this happened
what is the problem remaining the
problem remaining is that those internal
physical states are not conscious
so there isn't intentionality but what
i'm saying is that
the physicality is the extrinsic
appearance of what's going on
but the intrinsic view the thing in
itself those internal states are
phenomenal states because they cannot be
anything else
no no the problem is that intentionality
doesn't
i i i think this is a problem also for
physicalism but but right i'm
right and so i i i i think you're
mistaking what i'm trying to do
right intentionality is not like any
it's not like any physical i mean this
is brian kent well smith
i can be an intentional relationship to
things that i can
to things outside the light cone i just
did it i thought about it
that's the intent that's what it's about
but i'm not in causal relationship i
can't be
with things outside the light code i can
think about napoleon
and i can't be in causal relationship
with him because he doesn't exist
right anymore right intentionality is
not you can't
it's not reducible to causation in any
kind of easy fashion
and so i don't think you can just say
consciousness without intentionality
some causal process and then
intentionality
i analytical idealism doesn't solve
scientific problems
it provides an interpretation to
scientists
i think the problem of intention i think
intentionality is a philosophical
problem
but what you described as intentionality
just now like napoleon and what's
happening beyond the
event horizon of the cone of the
universe that we can see because the
light has already arrived
at where we are that's more complex than
i think the
normal definition of intentionality in
philosophy which is just
associated with perception
conscious state that reflects i don't
agree with that
you just i don't i don't think so maybe
maybe we're maybe we move in different
philosophical circles
the part of philosophy that overlaps
with cogsi is really really concerned
like take a look at like brian cantwell
smith he's a colleague of mine
at the university of toronto and you
know uh all of third wave
uh you know cognitive science is deeply
influenced by phenomenology and so
houston's notions of intentionality
uh which are supposed to do deal with
things like this
um are also pertinent issues and i and i
think
uh you know that's what cyril is talking
about he's talking about
the kind of intentionality that is born
in a language that's why he uses the
example of chinese right
he's not talking about just simple
perceptual he's talking about the kind
of intentionality
that's born in chinese i i assume that
chinese people can talk about napoleon
and they can talk about things outside
the light cone
i'm probably missing something in your
argument i i i don't see the problem
once the inner states
are conscious states associations will
be established through learning
between your inner states and your
social media
you can't get intentionality out of
association this is one of the problems
that bedevils
neural networks when neural networks are
firing
these two nodes are firing john these
three nodes john love and mary they're
all right associated with each other
but that that can't distinguish between
mary loves john and john loves mary yeah
which is an intentional difference
and that's that's that's a that's still
the existing problem for neural networks
that hasn't been solved
right i think that's a representation
problem because neural networks in
silicon as we do them to today digital
neural networks
uh they don't have uh symbolic anchoring
to
to the to the thing that is perceived
everything is encoded in bytes
uh which are symbols uh there is a there
is work done
by an ai researcher 17 years ago
begun 17 years ago penti heikon he used
to work at the nokia research
and he wrote a series of books about
conscious computers i think they are
flawed philosophically
but he makes this point clearly that if
you preserve
a semantic anchoring between the inner
representations of the computer
and the origin of that signal from a
certain quality of perception
that problem is solved the problem
arises because we encode things
arbitrarily
sorry i have to interject as a moderator
before we go forward some people are
are saying rightly so that they know
plenty more about bernardo's position
than they do
about yours john and that's because
bernardo's is so outside
the norm for us for the majority of
people that it's more interesting to
hear in many ways
i think it's also credit to how well he
articulates and defends his position i
think we should give credit to him it's
not just
thank you so much yeah it's not just
that it's uh
uh less familiar or novel i think he's
actually also you know
i also think so so john
do you mind giving the audience a
background as to what you
believe exist ontologically or what your
philosophical
point of view is well i tried to do that
at the beginning
um and there and and and part of the
reason why
i think bernardo and i are not just
shouting at each other is that there are
there are overlaps between our
ontologies
in certain ways um so i describe myself
as a naturalist
um which means uh as i said i'm not a
materialist because i don't think that
everything's made out of matter
i think that's a that's a ridiculous
claim um
i don't think you can do science with
pro-materialism i think scientists who
claim they're materialists
are engaging in performative
contradiction i think scientists have to
invoke
non-spatiotemporal relations uh to do
science
and berman and others have argued that
and therefore uh trying to reduce it
even to causal relations
uh and special temple relations i think
can't explain how you do science
um i do think that uh everything we do
has to be
consistent with what our science i don't
think bernardo is like
disagreeing with that either so i
completely agree
okay uh so thank you bernardo uh so i
my position is and again i'm not i i'm
not isolated
any more than bernardo is i think he's a
little bit more of a pioneer right now
i'll give him credit for that uh but
there are many people
um outside of like i would say like
neuroscience and things like that within
cognitive science
and that's the only audience i'm really
that conversant with
who would agree with what's called a
non-reductive physicalism
and this is the idea that you have to
count the layers at which we're doing
our science
the layers these are just metaphors by
the way the layers at which we're doing
science as real
as any other layer we point to with our
science because you get into all kinds
of contradictions
you don't so i think this world that i'm
experiencing right now
is as real as the world of quantum
probabilities
for example and and the pro and then you
and then and the reason with that is
like if you drop down to that level you
lose all the differences that are
required for science and required for
knowledge
required for information blah blah blah
i can do that in in at more length
but i'm not trying to defend it right
now i'm just trying to describe it i'm
just trying to show you that
it does come out of reasoning and
argumentation right and so
i think that they're and unlike many
people so this is where i'm
a bit of a pride here i'm much more of a
neoplatonous i think we have to talk
about equally about emergence and
emanation
i think there's ways in which real in
which uh
the possibilities of form are really
structured
and i don't equate actuality with
reality that's the influence of eastern
thinking on me i think that possibility
we have to treat possibility just as
real
as actuality and we do this with things
like potential energy
and stuff like that anyway and laws what
are laws laws aren't
advanced they're not actions they're
real constraints on what can happen
they're real and so as much as there is
emergence
bottom up from the physical substrata
there's emanation down from the
non-space
non-spatial temporal sets of constraints
on possib
possibility and some people say that
that's sort of cryptically
whitehead's god or something like that i
don't know if i have to go there
but i wouldn't say it's something like
the neoplatonic one
and you know and that's not really that
strange if you look
you if you look at the history if you
look at people you know john spencer's
work on the eternal law
other people like that a lot of the
people that brought about the
revolutions that we're talking about
right now
in science uh or that we're pursuing so
in our discussion about science
a lot of them had direct like explicit
connections to neoplatonism or similar
things
or they had connections to like einstein
with spinoza
and spinosus deeply in the neoplatonic
tradition he uses
uh you know he basically co-ops propolis
elements of theology
for the structure that he uses for the
ethics and things like that
um so what i'm saying is although i i
don't i want to be clear i'm not i i
don't present
that position a position you see in
people like john scottis irregina
of the complete complete
interpenetration as
um the consensus position i want to say
that there
are there have been uh notable people
within the history even the recent
history of science that have had
uh this position and very important
people in the history
of philosophy the whole neoplatonic
tradition um
uh especially post platinus uh john
scottis aerogena as an example
so i think that reality is
understood in the way our cognition
works
uh simultaneously bottom-up and top-down
fashion
that there are bottom-up causal
interactions top-down
uh constraints which aren't causes um
and they afford all of the structural
functional organization that accounts
for most of the phenomena that are uh in
dispute here
um i do think for example and i haven't
i haven't tried to make that argument
here people can look at it i have an
existing series out there i'm tangling
the world not
with greg enriquez i do think you can
fatten up access consciousness
uh so that you can get a lot of
phenomenal consciousness out of it
so one of the main things i argue is
that if you give a system intelligence
and you give it relevance realization
you're giving it foregrounding
and backgrounding of information you're
giving it as specialization
you're giving it a lot of what i call
the adverbial qualia the hear
the hereness and the noun-ness and the
togetherness of
consciousness which is not the same
thing as the standard qualia
of blueness and greenness and yellowness
and things like that
and the thing that's interesting about
those adverbial qualia is unlike the
adjectival qualia
they don't disappear in the pure
consciousness event
they're still there people describe the
hereness as
presence the nowness as eternity and the
togetherness is absolute unity
um so the adverbial quality has seemed
to be necessary and sufficient for
consciousness
and the adjectival qualia that gets so
many of these arguments going
i think aren't necessary and sufficient
for consciousness i don't think that
means they're unproblematic
i don't think i've solved that problem
but what i think i i would argue is that
we can thicken up
access consciousness to get a lot of the
phenomenology
of our consciousness and that makes me s
not so convinced that we won't be able
to cross the gap even more like we have
with
life and with intelligence so that's my
position
now i am not i hope i didn't come across
eric enough to claim that i have a
foreclosure argument
and that therefore i think bernardo is
insane
or his position is not intellectually
respectable far from it i wouldn't be
doing this if i
thought that but you were asking me to
state what my position is and that's
where my position is and so one
one more thing bernardo um i i like i
said i i
i i i want to be able to explain what i
think
is the base state of consciousness for
us and that for
bernardo said it might be the best
analog for cosmic
mind which is the pure consciousness
event and like i said
that that seems to be completely the
reason
we don't blank out and lose memory of it
is because it's not absolutely absent of
content it has no representational
conceptual propositional content
it has no adjectival content but it does
have
hereness now in his togetherness it does
have the adverbial
aspects and so i take those to be
something for which we might be able to
get
an overlapping explanation between them
and how intelligence works in terms of
relevance realization
and many of the people uh you know
uh you know bars is explicit that the
the function of consciousness is higher
order relevance realization
working memory lynn hasher is higher
order elements realization tononi
well his isn't about relevance
realization yeah he asked him for his
test
of intel of consciousness it's a test
for relevance realization to test for
appropriateness blah blah blah blah
say thing with clear means and his
caring higher order caring for lower
order representations
all the higher order ones because they
can't be inferential uh
involves some kind of uh appropriateness
or relevance thing
so a lot of the access models already
already converging on relevance
realization
and i think you can thicken that up if
you'll allow me a metaphor
to get a lot more of the phenomenology
that's my position
and um now that the thing about that is
that could the the the thing that's kind
of like going like this between bernardo
and i
is uh suppose that turned out to be
right
bernardo could still make his arguments
right his argument i don't think his
arguments ultimately
would be defeated if that turned out to
be right
uh because he see he he seems to be
running them and i don't mean seem in
the pernicious sense
it i'm just saying it is my judgment
that he seems to be running them on to
on
the basis of sort of more fundamental
features um and so
that's what i've been trying to get
clear about i hope that was fair to you
bernardo
i hope that wasn't a misrepresentation
can i ask a couple of clarifying
questions uh
john so do i understand correctly
that um adverbial qualia
can be reduced to pure non-phenomenal
access conscious in your consciousness
in your view
yeah i think although part of what i'm
trying to do is undermine
uh the the the clean distinction and
other people have noted
noted this for block right the clean
distinction between access and
phenomenal consciousness
um because people have pointed out well
there seems to be something it's what it
is like to access
right or to be poised and i take
poisonness
which is the defining feature of access
consciousness to be
a a metaphor for very sophisticated
relevance realization
that's what i take it to me that i will
bring out of my long-term memory
what's most appropriate and i will
structure it in my working memory
so that it best fits the environment
et cetera et cetera so you do think we
should be able in principle at least to
reduce
adverbial qualia to non-phenomenal
access consciousness if by what you'd
reduce is that i would be able to
give an explanation of how it arises out
of something
that is yeah that's what i mean by it uh
that doesn't mean that i think it's
ontologically reducible for reasons i've
already given
uh but yes oh so it could be that
that entity that's performing access
consciousness
has adverb adverbial qualia as
fundamental properties of it
at least in potentiality yeah
yes so i i that would make
a pen psychist of you um
it depends i mean and this is a debate
it depe and again we've had this debate
i don't know we'll resolve it
i mean it makes me a deep continuity
theorist um
and where whereas again is that
is that enough of a difference of degree
that it's a difference in kind
et cetera and so i take it the the
difference between the deep continuity
i mean i've had debates with jp uh more
so about this and he is a
pen psychist although he seems to be
loosening that um
that uh that there's a difference
between pan psychism and deep continuity
um and so that the explanatory
principles might be the same but that
doesn't mean the entity is the same
and and and we we do sort of countenance
that idea
because we use the same explanatory
principles for things that exist at
different scales for example
even spatial temporally et cetera et
cetera
and regarding um um ejectable
uh uh qualia those are more problematic
yes i do i do and but what i do think
um is that we
so this is a meta critique i think we
are holding
the topic of consciousness a hostage to
adjective qualia
when we have clear evidence for states
of consciousness if that's the right
word
like the pure consciousness event in
which adjectival qualia
are not present and i think if we had
adjective qualia without the adverbial
qualia
we would have a genuine human monster we
would have no togetherness hereness
nowness
uh to these experience and we would have
the humane
uh the human monster of these completely
atomic blips
of qualia and i don't think that would
constitute a consciousness anymore
they would still leave a problem there
but the integration problem would still
be exactly exactly exactly
yeah i i think i understand your view um
i do think the burden of argument is
more on you because
you would have then to explicitly make
sense of
how uh at least adverbial qualia can
emerge from
non-qualia simply because of a kind of
access configuration
um i understand that this is where you
were leaning
um i would point out that giulio tononi
himself has come out
biting the bullet and say fine fine itt
iit uh presupposed to spend psychics
so he sort of yeah oh well i think it's
because there are a lot of
the problems well this goes to another
issue um
and um
oh crap i was supposed to end at three
o'clock
uh uh i'm so sorry um
i'm sorry uh it's uh it's uh
no i don't want to make the move or i
say something uh but i mean i think
there's deep connections between
the hard problem of consciousness and
the hard problem of relevance um and i
don't think it's a coincidence
that all the all most of the theories of
the functionality of consciousness
are converging on the relevance
realization idea
um and i mean i make that argument
um and and then i do think that there's
important overlap between i've already
argued this between intelligence and
consciousness
in some fashion but i agree with you
it's not an intelligence
that has anything like intentionality or
meta-reflective capacities
and i think that has to be something
like a base relevance realization
ability
that we get um with that verbal qualia
so i'm trying to close the explanatory
gap
okay let's close this video as well
seems like you got to get going
yeah i i don't want to i don't want to i
don't want to sneak in a last word like
that
against bernardo i want to give you a
chest response
my last word is for you regardless of
whatever ontological differences
we seem to have john and i i think our
mission is
is the same or the reason why we are
doing what we do
is to address the meaning crisis i don't
use that term
but ultimately uh um i think uh we are
big buddies uh john we are allies yeah
in what we are trying to accomplish yeah
and there's a lot about what you say
that i think
is really important i mean i i don't
ultimately agree with you on some points
but i think you can see that there's
important ways in which
i am really significantly modifying the
standard
ontology to try and address some of your
concerns so at least
i at least think i'm responsible to your
concerns i
i know you don't have to you i'm not
asking you to agree with me but i am
asking you to see that i am responsible
to your concern
i acknowledge that and i appreciate it
very much
thank you very much for saying that i
want to thank you both
i'm i'm incredibly blessed and
i'm so lucky that i get to be a vessel
for
or cup for your holy water or your mana
at least temporarily so thank you so
much for that
i want to let the audience know about
where to find out more about you just in
a second
i also should let the audience know i've
been told i need to mention this
quite a bit more about i have a patreon
and i always feel slimy and
filled with discomposure when i talk
about that but
some people say just advertise it more
so if you want to see more conversations
like this
where there are kanye shentes like
bernardo and
john duking it out but also at the same
time loving one another
in their own manner please please do
visit patreon.com it
every dollar and literally every dollar
helps every patron helps and it helps me
extremely not only financially but
motivationally to
just to know that there are some people
that voluntarily they don't have to pay
you'll get this content no matter what
but they support it and that's i'm
well thank you so much with that said i
wanted to talk to you all about jesus
and buddha and what's the difference and
are they compatible
and what about god and free will and
there are quite a few more questions i
think
two or three i'm happy to talk with
bernardo again
i'm very happy being a delight and then
john is my brother
my brother-in-arms yeah very much i'd be
happy to talk with him again
great we'll arrange that again and if
anyone wants to know where to find out
more about you john and then bernardo
where do they go uh the best thing i
mean other than you know
doing academic search on google scholar
from my papers is you know go onto
youtube
go onto my channel look at awakening
from the meeting crisis
uh which is about the beating crisis of
course you could take a look at
a a a dialogical series i did with greg
enriquez about consciousness
called untangling the world not by the
way bernardo that's a that's a reference
to schopenhauer
uh right entangling the world not of
consciousness um and then i'm currently
doing one
called the elusive eye the nature and
function of the self
uh with uh greg enriquez again and
christopher master pietro
uh so that would be so and then if you
want to see more of these kinds of
dialogues on my channel i have an
ongoing dialogical series called voices
with reiki
where i try to exemplify how we can
weave together
argumentation and genuine deal logos
bernardo just go to bernardocastrop.com
there's a lot of
free stuff linked from there okay
great and if you all want i can give you
the video files for this once it's up on
our site if you
want to use it as extra content on yours
you're more than welcome to
thank you so much again thank you this
was
far different in in a positive manner
than i
expected it to be i'm glad that i took a
backseat because it's mainly about
like i said theo maki but also theo
locution so
thank you i'm happy that you were yeah
and i wanted to thank you you helped us
to steer out of getting locked into
local minima
that i thought was indeed we're very
helpful for both of us
so thank you thank you bernardo great
great pleasure meeting you great
pleasure indeed enormous pleasure from
my side as well john great to
meeting you and getting to know you
let's do this again i'm happy to do so
and not not i love don i love don
hoffman
but i'm actually i'm glad that he wasn't
here because it would be far too many
voices
and it was great to see you all get to
know one another and try and understand
each other's viewpoints thank you
excellent
take care everybody take care have some
chocolate john bye bye okay
bye-bye
you